Let me tell you something.
You know how bad to the bone I do this.
I was just still on the way up beat
Eddie Bravo is the one who called me and
reached, turned me on to Tom Petty.
Tom Petty was bad about the firearm.
That fucking, that something
song was on the way up. Yeah.
I almost crashed the fucking cop.
He doesn't get much respect.
I don't know why people when
they talk about like rock stars,
they really love you don't hear a lot of
people like people go off about like I
always go off back a Hendrix or
people go off about certain artists,
but you don't hear that much of a
fucking Anthea. That's that what it is.
But you don't like Getty Lee, same thing
for us. That fucking guy drives me crazy.
Yeah, no, that shit drives me crazy.
It's singer from reo Speedwagon with
the needle shoulders and Mario Spit,
which had a good life
back when we were kids.
That was a bad ass fucking or we'll come
back back on the Road Gan given that
what time I'm leaving, uh,
they were fucking bad ass.
But the prom with Tom Petty's,
it looks like a rat.
But if you know anything about Tom Petty,
he's deep in it. Dog. He's like, Hey,
he's a good Gracie. He took guitar
lessons from the guitar player,
from the Eagles in high school.
Did you get from that area where
white people and I trash white trash,
but they know how to fucking play an
instrument like, like at Jacksonville,
that area. He's from like
Jackson's though. Uh, okay.
So Jacksonville is like them.
Uh, you know, not to let us get it,
but the other band that was, uh,
that Jackson's the Allman brothers
like gap. You can see it. Oh,
I get it now I get the whole,
Oh,
that's what the Allman brothers
from Florida to yas, Bro,
that neighborhood is leaked. Or like
if you go online, that neighborhood,
like I went online one day, um, I know
that it's either or either Tom Petty.
Just think about that.
The guitar player from Eagles,
the one that wrote Hotel California,
when they threw out that lives right
up in Topanga Canyon. That dude,
that dude's a powerhouse,
all that [inaudible] now all that was him.
Joe Walsh joined later.
But the early power house was that dude
when he has rings around his nose on
Hotel California with blow, that dude's
a savage and he and the high school,
he gave Tom Petty Guitar lessons
and people don't know that.
And they can you imagine and that's
like, that's like, you know, that's like,
that's like the Machados Gracie's
like they were just hanging out in the
basement. They were cousins.
That's what they did.
And they all launched from there.
The Allman brothers.
It's gotta be somebody
else from that area.
I don't know who it is that's
from that fucking area.
A lot of people don't know that. That's a
weird, you're getting it from that area.
Yeah, I mean just get it. Oh,
I'm in brothers and Tom Petty.
I know for a fact I could,
I can't lose this argument.
Tom Petty's got 10 songs that
we've all sung at one time.
That fucking song from when
the guys dancing naked and
the, and silence Atlanta.
So there's Dick between his legs,
American girl. That's all time batty guys.
That's all time patty. The one with
Brock, the dude that good looking guy.
Pirates of the Caribbean.
Remember he had that video with the dude
from the pirates of the Caribbean with
dance, with Mary Jane Doe. That dude
does not the one with Stevie
nicks when we were kids.
Stop dragging my heart around. Fuck
yeah, I forgot about me not gonna. Look,
I'm getting goosebumps cause
he's like Muhammad Ali.
He just stuck around for 20 that's
83 it's 2000 fucking 15 that's seven.
That's 17 that's 32 fucking years.
I know he's still around and he's still,
he's still around. Wow. You know, you
forget about those fucking guys. Like how,
but that area, what is the
water? It's gotta be something.
They just had something at that time.
You know what that was like.
They're all growing up in the 70s and
the culture was probably exploding from
the whole,
all the crazy shit from the 60s a lot of
people from the east coast escaped and
they went down to Florida. You know,
that's what happened to a lot of people.
A lot of mob guys went down to Florida.
A lot of people went down to
Florida to go on the land.
A lot of people went down to Florida to
get away from debts to get away from the
east coast like the Florida is a big part
of Florida is like escape savages from
like Jersey and New York. That's a,
that's the dirty secret about Florida.
There's as many New York accents
and some parts of Florida.
Is there anywhere else you want to Tampa?
Yeah,
Yankee hot dogs and that's where
the Yankees spring training. Listen,
when I rubbed that jewelry store,
I went to Sarasota and the laminate
e three that was nothing to do.
I had to go to watch the road
warrior every day for a month.
I got it was theory about Florida.
I got a theory about Florida.
I think it's too hot. I think that's
why people are so dopey down there.
I think it's too hot. No, I think you can.
If you take those animals from New
Jersey and New York that was in the set,
they're like, it just got there.
They just got their, they,
their personalities were
developed in the cold weather.
Their personalities would develop it.
You've got to get shit done. It's cold.
You got a fucking shovel your car out and
then you'd go down to Florida and it's
just swatting bugs and sweating.
Just that deep,
deep fog of a hot day in Miami fog.
The fog of the moisture in the air.
Fuck.
What about an Arizona though?
We didn't know that. My aunt,
southern Florida morning,
you know when you're there when you wake
up and there's dew on the window and
you opened up and it smells
tremendous of a flyer.
The morning Chenelle was tremendous.
That grass with that moisture on it.
But now tell me about this thing
outside of Fort Lauderdale.
You were telling me once and then somebody
was telling me in Fort Lauderdale one
time, what's going to happen in that
ocean? It's going to sink. There's,
there's an area around Miami,
like all around southern Florida,
which the ground is very porous.
It's,
it's not like Louisiana where you can
like put up a levee and you can keep the
water from coming in. You can't stop
it. It's going to come through the,
through the ground. The
ground is not this, you know,
rock hard from ground that we get up
here while we're right next to the water.
It's not like that.
So as the water level rises,
it's going to be no way to stop it. It's
going to come right through the ground.
Swampy. Yeah. When it comes to the
ground, that's the everglades and that's,
you know, any, any swampy type area.
And when it comes to the ground,
it's gonna eat up Miami. It's just going
to eat it up. It's not going to last.
Miami not going to be here in a hundred
years ago. Who used to say that?
Do you know who my mother's, that's why
she didn't go to Miami. She's smart.
She left Cuba, kept asking, why didn't you
ever go to Miami? Those Cubans? She goes,
and I'm like, it that. She goes,
they position those missiles
from there to shoot or something.
She was telling me,
Oh yeah,
that's where I don't want to fucking human
being something about Miami. The land,
the land's not going to be right there.
And she hated it.
She fucking hate in Miami with a passion,
especially in her era. Uh, you know,
that was when the Cuban missile crisis
was going on and everybody felt that the
Russians are going to launch nukes
from Cuba's right there. I mean,
a lady swam it, she swam it. I mean,
what the fuck man do you
mean you could probably,
I mean it people, everyday
people raft it, that little boy.
Remember that little rap that every day
when you go to Cuba right now and you
put it on this street, I'm digging
it, going out this be some Guy Mackey,
and he'll break it down to you don't
leave at six because the high tide,
they already have it. They've
done it. They've done it,
and maybe come back and got arrested in
Cuba and the United States and come back.
You know,
they said there's a point when you're out
there that you just see all the wraps.
If people that have failed, oh my God.
And that's when, you know there's like 30,
40 miles out of Miami, you know, uh,
50 miles out of the United States.
They say it crack a lot.
That's where you really tight.
That's the fifth round.
And this is silver is on top of your
ground and pounding and you're, you know,
it's, you're just looking into
the abyss. There's nothing.
And once it gets dark they say you just
hear some fucking wall noises, man.
Oh,
so fucking while noisy.
No,
you can't drink the salt water.
So you got to bring the water with,
you got to keep the raffle light. So
you've got to bring like saltine crackers.
I mean it's, it's any days it take, it's
all depending on the time, you know,
I don't really know.
I've spoken to people who have done it.
Cubans that you up to like listen to
your conversation about the fucking show
last night and listened to
this like they have yet.
And all the fucking documentaries they
do have not sat down like a family like
that came with six and they lost three.
And you talked to those mother
fuckers and you haven't,
don't look at the picture from
the Yankees. Eight his hand,
he started cannibalizing
his own fucking hand. What?
Because he and then he broke down in it.
I get emotional thinking of just
like psychological, psychological.
He started eating his hand,
had no food, so when he,
the first time the Yankees
gave him 10 million,
he went into the clubhouse and he
saw the cold cuts and he broke down.
He had a nervous breakdown.
He had never seen that much food like
fruit and cold cuts and bread and you know
sodas. He had never seen that.
That's just the intensity of it,
but there's nobody yet. There's
a, there's a documentary.
It's real interesting and
called bud settle about size.
That's that generation. The Cubans having
the Marielle escape, Lomaia lethal.
Those are the ones that
came in [inaudible] 79 and
then you have the 90s ones
and they called the Cubans look down on
them. The Marielitos like, fuck you punks.
Your boss said it was, they're the
ones that come and truck tires.
Jesus fucking truck.
How many days does it take?
Normally three to at all.
You know,
I this be intelligent people watch the
show and that sitting there going Joey,
it all depends.
It's not like you could count the
days wherever the tide takes you,
you know it was going to be, my
question is do people ever miss I? Why?
Do you ever like go? Does it take
you out to see every x? Some people,
the tie goes a different direction.
I'm sure that when you go to,
they have the jets rooms.
I mean not the jet streams,
like pretty predictable.
Like that's how they have
those garbage patches, right?
Some people get caught in
those islands by The Bahamas.
You have to look at the
map and we could really,
some people actually landed on
the island by the heart pump.
You're still not home because you're
still, they could still a restaurant.
So if I'm choke, Fidel has flights going
through out there looking for people.
Those mother fuckers,
they get back to Cuba and a restaurant.
So until you touch the United States,
what are you writing? A tide map.
There's such things as tight
naps for boating and stuff.
That would show you the tides of the
eye unless you touch the sec. So,
so close. So those islands
right there from, I see the tip,
you probably have to leave from the
northwest dial, like right under key west.
You'd have to leave.
But I guarantee there's a problem.
I guarantee there's some type of problem.
So you have to hit it
depending on what's going on.
Some people live lead lead from the
southern point and they catch something at
The Bahamas,
those little islands,
The Bahamas has over a hundred
little islands over there,
a hundred little islands by The Bahamas.
All those little islands used
to be drug smuggling islands.
That's the midway point. So
that, that, that's it right
there. But think about that.
That's 90 miles. That's from head
to San Diego. That's a legit,
so the first 30 miles is pretty easy.
The next 30 of the real fucking deal.
And then I imagine you start seeing
land, but uh, once you run out of water,
you start hallucinating when you
can't drink the salt water. Correct.
So you started loosening.
I mean,
I've heard different things and
let's put that back up again, Jamie.
That'd be a very interesting documentary
that just see somebody take off from
Cuba and fucking just
like a survivor man thing,
but that seems like something he was,
yeah,
that's a look at that fucking look
at the distance. It's so small.
She would looks bigger
than I thought it looked,
but these maps were really like distorted.
It's very difficult to
gauge the perspective, like
how big Cuba actually is.
Like a, when you look at like Africa
and the United States on a map,
like a lot of times it doesn't look
like Africa's that much bigger.
But then if you actually
see how big Africa is,
if you ever seen that Africa fits like
almost all the other countries, it's like
you're, yeah, it fits everything.
Like pull up a map of how many different
countries fit inside Africa because
it's, it's pretty crazy to look at. It's,
it's so big. Look at
that. That's All Africa.
So I look at all the different
fucking Sylvia, the United States.
It's like a little piece of it.
It's like maybe a quarter of it.
Look all of eastern Europe. China.
Yup. China fits in in, in Africa.
That's how big Africa is. Spain,
France or excuse me, for Rawls,
Germany, Italy, eastern
Europe and fucking India.
Good Lord.
And then it says India part too.
So I guess that's another segment of
India or they just stuffed in there and I
made it feel like a fucking Africa. And
that's when you just get petrified. Oh,
and all the UK,
the whole UK fucker.
When you see what's an Africa is when
you really fucking just shut the map.
Like you're like,
I could sell y the x asis was that
cause in my mind the exorcism is dead.
That's where it started. Look at the
fucking countries, like everywhere.
There's always a fucking
fentanyl going on.
Always something going on
Morocco that smoking Hash,
Tunisia who fucking know Libya.
They fucking up, you know,
Sudan and fucking up Egypt.
That fucking Ethiopia is the fucking
up look at all the fucking reason.
You know Rwanda, there's a war always. I
mean there's always signed goal, a Zombie.
I mean there's always something.
So Bob Way, Africa, Zimbabwe,
Somalia, the most corrupt city in
the world supposed to be Nigeria.
Nigeria is that Nigeria, one of those
where they have all the uh, Ma, uh,
the scams on emails where your
money's in an African Bank.
That's the most corrupt
city, the cops, everything.
Everything goes down in Africa.
Look at that, look at
that. Where's the Liberia?
You ever see those of vice specials on
Liberia and fucking of Somali and pirates
come fucking crazy mother
fuckers that are out there. Yeah.
Well you know the Somalian pirates,
you know how it all got started.
There were fishermen and a,
the Europeans kept dumping shit into
the ocean and they were killing all the
fish are throwing like nuclear
waste overboard and shit
and all kinds of fucking
chemical pollutants.
They just would dump their waste out
outside the shore of Somalia and it was
killing all their fish and these people
were starving so they started kidnap and
these boat guys and you know, holding
them for ransom saying, hey, you owe us.
You've been fucking up our ocean.
You know we want money and they were
making so much money doing that.
They said fuck fishing and they just
started robbing people and they take this
stuff called cat. It's like
a, it's like an amphetamine.
It's a plant that they chew and that
it has like an amphetamine effects.
So they're fucking just hopped
up on speed all day long,
just gay and they're running around
with guns and they're just fucking,
they give a f zero fucks.
They don't give a fraction of a fuck.
When they get on those speed boats
and head towards your oil tanker,
they start throwing anchors up there,
grappling hooks and
shit pull themselves up.
They're just not scared of you at all.
Their crazy fucks those guys are,
have you ever seen videos with those
guys? But they're scary. It's scary.
They're wild man. They come after people
up, going on the ship around. Anyway,
with those motherfuckers out there,
in a lot of ways it's very lord of
the rings s you know, it's like,
it's kind of like unbelievable when you
see these groups of dudes that are all
skinny and kind of cracked out and they
got machine guns and then her a rubber
tube with a fucking engine attached to
it and they're shooting at this giant
boat and they throw it hooks up
and climbing up, getting inside.
How is that any different than some
scenes from the Lord of the Rings?
That's crazy. That's like the elves
versus the trolls and Shit, you know?
I mean these guys are mad men.
The Matton men and most likely all that
shit started out because people were
fucking with their livelihood.
They're like a peaceful fishing village
and people were polluting their water
and they didn't have any food,
so they started getting dangerous.
They started getting desperate. That's
a crew. They call themselves the,
the volunteer coast guard of Somalia.
That's what they started off as.
It makes sense. Fucking totally makes
sense. Why they would be so angry. Well,
I mean, well, how come
they never did it before?
How come Somalia doesn't have like a
deep history of pirating? You know,
it's not like we know, you know, it's not
like we think of them as like Vikings.
You know, if Vikings started
robbing people again, we'd be like,
it's in their blood.
The video I seen,
there wasn't one FESA Molly and
they're all fucking bony up like Jesus,
this skinny as fuck.
And they move Jack.
They pull up next to a ship and they
move. It's like flux, Swat. Fuck.
These guys don't give a fuck. And they
throw all this shit out of, they lock up.
But these guys don't get wet.
And like the legal,
it looks like Jimi Hendrix or goggles on.
He doesn't know about fashion. Not Can,
you know, it's uh, it's fucking
scary. I Dunno. Different world.
It's a different for fog. You grow up
in that world and stayed out here, man.
Those more the fuck is a savage is
like real living fucking savages.
And it's kind of interesting,
Joe,
if you really think about it like we don't
have to be like that, but here we are.
It's 2015 in the same time when you
and I are alive and very peaceful and
getting along with everybody. This is
going on in another part of the world.
That's, that's the weird
thing. It's like there's,
we're not much different than them. We
just, we was just, we're super lucky.
We're super lucky. We got born
into a better situation than them.
These people are there right now in a
war zone. That's like a Mad Max movie.
I mean their life in a
lot of parts of Africa,
their life might as well be some crazy
end of the world apocalypse movie.
You know, if you go to watch the
watch, the vice pieces on Liberia,
it's Candace. This is like
some of the shit. Fuck yeah.
That's what part of it is. Okay.
Right. The cannibalism selling.
He said this guy was selling meat like
human meet on the street in Kabobs and he
said he recognized it because he knows
what human meat tastes like because he
used to kill babies as
he used to fight naked.
This guy to calm general button naked.
He would take off all his fucking clothes
and going into combat with a machine
gun, naked killing everybody
killed thousands of people,
thousands of people.
Eight babies used to cut their heart out.
You can find an innocent child of,
of the enemy killed them,
cut their heart out and eat pieces of
their heart and they were immune to, to,
to being damaged in battle. They
couldn't die. That's what they felt.
So they would do that. He's admitting
this on this fucking special.
Now here's where it gets really crazy.
He became religious afterwards and now
he's like a minister and he teaches,
he preaches Christianity and because of
that they're going to absolve him for
all of the people he's killed.
Who, who? The same guy,
the country of whatever country he's
in and I be Liberia. They absolve him.
They like let him off the
hook because he's like a
Christian now. It's like, Whoa,
like this is going on right now.
I mean,
that guy killed thousands of people,
thousands and admits on camera that that
part of their ritual was to eat babies
and people were like, well, you know
it's a, he's different now. Now he's,
he's found Jesus guy.
He's got to pay for this somewhere.
This one with the next one.
But what my point was is like
this is a very different world.
How please not just a little limits,
it's another day, Jack. It's another day.
Traffic to us is another day.
People somewhere else in the standards.
These mother fuckers ain't and kids arts,
babies' hearts not only die like how
many atheists do you think are in Africa?
I Bet I bet a lot less
about a lot less than here.
So when a guy says something like, I've
found God now, now I've found Jesus.
That actually means something
to them. Whether they go, wow,
he's found God like this is,
you're talking about a world that looks
like a movie. That's what Africa is.
I mean it's a world that looks like
a move, like a crazy chaotic movie,
like an asteroid hits China and kills
almost everyone outside of the United
States and kills 30 40% of the United
States and then that that's Africa,
the highly populated areas and be
like Africa [inaudible] nine yeah.
That movie just took nine very, very
similar. Yeah, that's part of it.
I mean then you also have Johannesburg.
They also have like real stories.
I mean it's weird to just
so it's so fucking giant.
I think the craziest thing I was so out
of where I am was like the Bronx in the
80s I certain parts of the Bronx,
I would leave there like going,
I'm going to have a common here again.
That was a crazy,
should we ever saw here again.
Yeah.
I can write one that I made a mistake
like in 1980 and went through the Bronx to
get drugs.
I thought I was cool with some friends
and we fucking went into a war zone.
They were wars,
which I don't know who was fighting.
I have no idea but it was
just dark and weapons. Nah,
I like the regular things. I don't need
to be in this fucking, that's the worst.
I saw. I would a building on fire and
not, I went, there was a building on fire,
people yelling at the fire department.
We didn't even go in because they know
that the fucking people would rob him.
It was like that movie I told you
to watch robbed about Ken Norton.
Muhammad I late that.
It wasn't that that Muhammad Ali lost
to Ken Norton that night. The decision,
it was what was going on
outside in New York City.
How people getting robbed on the streets.
He you have him for the cops and the
cops are turning their backs because they
were overwhelmed.
It was like four to one.
They couldn't get all the cops and there
they had blocked. They did it perfectly.
They block cars and shit so no
horses could get him at nothing.
I'm telling you watch this.
You're going to be like, what?
How did this happen in 1970 that people
from Manhattan rich are getting mugged
and they are yelling for
the cops to help him.
And the cops were walking away like
that's how crazy the Bronx was at one time
when I was a kid and I didn't go up.
That didn't live up there.
I'm going to pet it, get
drugs thinking, you know,
like coke or weed or something
stupid. That's the worst. Well,
there's so many people.
The Bronx is so huge.
There's so many people in like bad
neighborhoods like or quote unquote bad
neighborhoods, you know, lower class,
poor neighborhoods in New York there's,
there's big areas, big giant areas
that have like a lot of, you know,
what's the correct onset, lower class.
What do you want to say? Like, uh,
people that live in poverty, but
there's, there's some spots, you know, I,
uh, when the first one, the first
things I did when I moved to New York,
because I drove to Harlem and I'm like, I
want to see what this is like, you know,
I'm like, all right, I got
here. It was my first day here.
Let me go see what Harlem is like.
Fucking drove all the way up and as you
get uptown and things get weirder and
Weirder,
and this is 90 1990 and it was before
they cleaned up times square to it was,
it was still kind of a freaky
spot and as I'm driving up there,
it just started getting crazier and
crazier and then all the sudden you're in
neighborhoods where you're like,
I have to get the fuck out of here.
Like this is, this is not
safe. Like this dangerous.
I was driving through a spot that
had garbage that was stacked seven,
eight feet high,
five feet wide,
stacked down blocks.
I mean put blocks.
There was like long blocks of
garbage hills and you're like,
what the fuck is going on? Where there's
some sort of a garbage strike for,
I don't know what the details were,
but there was rats running back and forth.
You could see him running back and
forth. And you know, I grew up in a,
like when I lived in Boston,
I lived in a suburb in Newton.
That's why I went to high school. It
was like the calmest, quietest place.
It's very nice place.
So here I am just a couple of years
removed from that and I'm walking down
Harlem,
watch these rats dart back and forth
and people are stepping out of liquor
stores holding 40
ounces like it's a movie. I'm
like, Whoa, this place is crazy.
This place is crazy.
For 16 from 15 to 22 that was my backyard.
Really.
My backyard was from a hundred and 13th
and fifth which is right by the park to
178 by port authority and Joe Rogan.
I had,
I knew every nook and cranny like I knew
where all the weed was. The coke was,
the pills were, the weapons were white
and I had, I had been pretty much the,
I had been pretty much my mom's best
friend lived on 113th and the fifth and
that was a horrible by the at night.
That turned into something else.
And then with it being
in the number of state,
when I was a kid with my parents were
the Cubans have their main numbers thing
is by a place called La Marqueta.
There's a train and they have all these
little markets and it's on a hundred and
18th and a used to be Spanish back in
and then the seventies sixties and early
eighties and what you do as my mom would
have a bodega and she'd have sodas and
cigars and maybe books or dreams
and people come in and they say,
I had a dream about a truck
getting hit by a fucking monkey.
I Trump this 50 and a monkey's three.
So they put $5 on three 50 you know,
and $5 pays you $2,500 that night.
Cash,
no fucking drama. And all the banks
would be upstairs. So the Bot,
you'd have bodegas all around Harlem,
but the bank would be centralized on one
building. And the summers I would have,
I would have a couple of
different jobs in the summers.
I would either help them to Bodegas,
you know,
stocking shelves and
running money up the stairs,
or I answered the phones and how to
yell the numbers to the dude's and they
would flip it.
So if you get too much action,
let's say on 604 after you get
$50 on that number, you got to,
let's say you get $82 on that number,
you have to take $32 and dump it off to
a different bank because you could only
get killed if you give away $50 that
means you're losing $25,000 for the day.
So it was always happening.
It's a very interesting fucking racket.
It's not huge anymore because the
picket came in. So the lottery,
the one of the biggest lotteries,
I don't know if they still do as a
Puerto Rican lottery, you buy the sheets,
you buy it by the sheets and that's big
and that part of the country. But uh,
their talent, it was invented by Strap
Santo traffic, aren't they? In Miami?
And he brought it from Cuba
and it's called policy. So
then the Italians took it.
They were a big thing of it,
but the ethnics were where the monies
that they're the ones that have the dreams
and that poor. So that's what the
ethnic took that market from the Mafia.
He said how ironic.
It's a lottery is coming for the all
that money's coming from the poor people
playing it.
People that have the dream.
The next time you go to seven 11 and
you go get where you want rolling papers
and you're fucking thirsty. Look who's
in front of you. Some fucking guy. Huh?
Let me get the tech health floor,
which you know he's in
fucking seven or 11 eh,
this fucking Isis substation
with a fucking dream. He's
going to win the lottery.
You know,
it's a fucked up dream.
I see people in my seven 11 all
the time buying 25 30 tickets,
but I also, part of it makes me giggle.
A lot of it reminds me of being a kid.
My mom,
my mom's number habit was Harvard
hall played the numbers constantly.
If she walked in here and you have like,
what's the sand Cronk 31 give
me the number before 31 Jo,
five blank called New York.
Five 31 $20 Bam.
So anywhere she went and she
saw a number that was weird.
She blast that motherfucker.
The only times I hit the number when I
was a kid just fucking around with her.
I would have joined like a football
team and I would come home and she'd go,
what's that number on your shirt?
57 put a number in front of that five.
She called the book, five
57, $10 $5,000 for dinner.
Another time I hit it
on my birthday to 19.
I used to hit that motherfucker
constantly on my birthday,
but that was my mother's fucking main
thing was numbers, numbers in Harlem.
So I got to walk around there as a child.
Then as I got older,
my first arrest wasn't home.
I got caught smoking weed
on 160 first street in 1983.
The first day after the
Superbowl, I want $800 on the, uh,
when the triple, what's the Miami?
These, the, the sleeping and the bees,
whatever the fuck they were
when they beat the Redskins.
And I went into a health food store.
In those days we'd stores were
health food stores in Harlem.
So what does the health food store can
complain of you who's no protein drinks
in those days it was it
protein powder, you know,
vitamins.
And then if you knew the right people,
you want to know you're not in
the glasses wall bulletproof. Wow.
And you went in and they, you'd say,
what do you have? Let me get to raise.
And they,
excuse me,
they put the weed and the glass you
take and give them the $30 and you'd ask
permission can I wrote it in the corner
and you rolled the joint in the corner
and then you could go
outside and smoke it.
I wrote it in the corner and when I lit
it in the corner, because it was windy,
it was January, when I went to
put the light into the joint,
a fucking mailman put a gun to my head
and he goes, get on the floor. He goes,
if you got more than 20 singles on you,
I'm going to beat the fuck outta here.
I got on the floor,
I had 800 I had one 800 probably
had seven 40 and he goes,
what'd you get this money from me and
I want some cops started pulling up and
they were looking for people who was
selling loose joints to kids two blocks
away. So when they realized
I lived in Jersey and,
and I had no idea in those days,
I didn't walk with an ID dog.
My word was my shit. No idea. In
those days I throw away the ID,
fucking no idea. You
want it, you're a cop.
Figure it out the fuck you're
fucking conquer or the tactic.
Figure it out, bitch. And the cop
told me, tell me the truth, your name.
I told him the truth. And they put
my finger on one of those things.
That was the early technology.
New York had lake three vans
that have that shit on it,
fingerprint thing and it came back. Jose
Diaz and blast, they let me go. In fact,
the cop took wheat out of my bag,
put it on the floor and said,
now it's nine grams. I you could
keep it and I'll give you a ticket.
And that was my first legitimate arrest.
I got arrested for that in Manhattan.
I did six months,
the first sentence.
And I moved to Colorado and I had to
write the guy a letter on the first and
call him on the fifth and they let me go.
So they looked at your fingerprints
and they found your name for the quick
quick. And I was never, never
been arrested before. Never.
So how are your fingerprints in the
record? Wouldn't know. Fuck him.
I the hospital maybe. I have no
idea. I didn't ask no questions.
That's interesting. I wonder
if everybody's finger, I mean,
especially with like apple,
like that was one of the big things
that people were worried about with the
iPhone Raaga already on again. Yeah.
That apple thing is fucking up or ready.
Well,
I'm not even talking about that.
I'm just talking about the ability to
use your fingerprint because you can get
your fingerprint from this. Like
as you're pressing it, right? It's,
it's leaving your fingerprint and that's
how it recognizes your fingerprint.
And the idea is that that all
goes to a database. You know,
we want to know if Joey Diaz touched
anything with his finger. Well,
let's look at the database. Oh look this,
we got his fingerprint. It's right here.
Run it. And so they have your
fingerprint at my school.
They did it in middle school.
We all had to clarion thumbprints down on
both sides. And it was kind of like we,
we learned about thumbprints, prints and
we're like, where did that go? You know,
we just, I don't remember
whether or not I did that,
but I probably did it when I was a kid.
P A L I was a big PA guy.
You weren't sure if you didn't have the
police athletic league. You want to shit.
Really? Yeah. When I was a kid out of
12 we won. I came from Cuba. There was,
they taught you how to play pool.
They look fucking listen.
They would just regular
comps and this was that.
This is a job to get away
from their wives with the pal.
There's a bunch of Puerto Rican
kids and I little Irish dirty kids.
And what's a great way to
make a relationship with
the cops today? What Bro?
They tonight to fucking the precinct
and they let you shoot a gun. They kept,
you kept a target.
You kept a bullet.
They fingerprint that year they took
a picture of you and you did. It was,
they took us on fucking basketball trips.
They took us to the Yankee stadium.
I had a great relationship. But then in
like the seventh grade, eighth grade,
Mr. Moreno,
it took us to fucking Detroit for a
little bitty basketball tournament and we
found some guy in the street that buys
a case of beer and it was all a little
bit the fucking shot Jack. That
mother fucker said, it's over.
We're not even playing a game.
He drove him was right back home.
We didn't get to play a game.
We drove debt and get a case of beer
and we drove right back for eight hours
right back to fucking jersey. So
I'm a, I'm a p a l I always was.
So maybe that's how they
got my fingerprints. Was,
was that the end of the
relationship with pa out? Uh,
no. I think I used to still go for,
it wasn't why I grew up in Jersey.
The pal or is geared more towards boxing.
When I was in New York City, it was a, it
was a place that they had like a boxing,
they had a pool table, they had a,
you know, sodas and shit like that.
Activities you may like ceramics and
shoe depending on your age. And Jersey.
It was more Mr Gameo.
Mr Gameo was a Cuban dude.
He ran the boxing program and I used
to know his two sons, Julio and season.
They got me a job at putting on
the field and they were like,
listen to when you get the job,
you got to rob Putnam fields right
by Seacaucus off of route three.
It's dirty truck. People
go in there. Any job.
I lasted about three weeks
before they fired me,
but I left that and after three weeks
the guy at night was a half a momo.
His name was Freddy,
even though it's telling you this,
so we robbed the one that we go listen,
we're just going on and be Freddy up.
We were like sophomores in high school.
We'll put mask on me and deedee
can Tara and when he comes out,
because in Jersey you pay the gas guy,
you don't go into a store,
you know they pump your gas.
So if you robbed the Guy,
you basically robbed the joint.
Do you follow me?
Only Oregon and New Jersey is where the
people pump your gas. Everybody else.
You walk in with a cart, so we were kids.
We were like, let's rob fucked up. Freddy,
you know when I worked at,
I got to know Freddy Freddy's wife
looked like honey boo boos mother,
but he was a little guy but he,
his wife was like 400 pounds and the only
way she would let him fucking as if he
brought below home and he was a skinny,
tiny guy like Eddie Bravo.
She was like three 90 and she would
actually put the Bikini and they,
they were such white trash.
They lived in a studio apartment and they
would rent the Jacuzzi and putting the
living room.
These people were fucking,
they lived on the third floor
studio did your part, but my God,
and it was the worst building in the
neighborhood and they had black model.
She was the only black girl in
the neighborhood, black bottle.
I don't know what black Marlowe is today,
but she's the Real Martin Luther King.
She was the only black girl in a
white neighborhood and Jersey thugs.
That girl torture. She got tortured.
I always loved Black Marlo.
Marlo was tight with me. Her mother was
white. Something had happened for houses,
fucked up. That building was fucked up.
So I used to go with it as selling blown.
I remember Freddy opening up the door
and they were like a robot and his,
his fat wife and living with heels
with a bikini on and he's like,
thank you for bringing it to me.
Like he really was like,
when you brought them the blow, he was
fucking thankful that you fucking like,
thank you man. I'm
like, we'll see tonight.
Like she would not give me my hand job
if he didn't have blow. So finally,
so finally one day me and Deedee can tell,
we decided,
let's go down there and rob this
motherfucker on a Saturday night.
Let's wait until about midnight when he's
got a grand on them because you don't
drop two,
you get 2000 so every 2000 you'll make
a drop in the floor safe and you can't
get back in there.
So me and Dee Dee went behind the building
by sea cock and there was right next
to this hot dog place,
snappy nappies.
The rumor was that's what the ice man
killed somebody and put them in a tank by
snapping that it's, no, this
is a real fucking area jersey,
this is across the street was one of the
biggest strip clubs in the east coast.
Not when I was there. Robin. Freddy couple
of years after that, like the army base.
So you remember if you lived in New York,
they called us to the air force
base some basis, some shit.
But when we were kids we went there
like at 12 and we took Freddy down dog.
We just tagged with a
master like kicking him.
Like they kicked the whatever his name
is and that Deniro movie in the bar and
we took his little person, we ran away
and he gets it like it took him a week.
He's like, you guys robbed me last
night cause we had masks on and shit.
We're like Freddy, it wasn't us. He's
like, yeah, so was I heard your voices.
Then he came back to us. He's like,
listen, I'll let you rob be once a month,
but you got to split the money with me.
So I could buy an eight
ball to fuck my wife.
So once a month we go down
and give a steady Freddy,
you're beaten and we kick
the fuck out of them.
Just I'm pressing let you do it. He
wanted to with the cops, you know,
that's the only way to cops and we
did it like eight times. So rob,
did you give him black eyes?
Bloody noses.
Some of the stomach couple of times
that we need them. Neon belly,
I don't even know what it was.
No video back then either.
She had it leave marks on them. Yeah,
you have like kick him a few times.
I couldn't do it. I had too much of
a heart, so I always had a higher,
like I had to bring like
one of my crazy friends
that was having like a bad week. There's
a kid in Miami today that everyone,
every time I place south Florida,
he shows up with his girlfriend and he
gets fucked up and he tells a story.
When I knocked on his door with a diagram
on how we were going to rob Freddy and
he goes, that's when I knew that
you were fucking for real. He goes,
I was eating dinner with my family.
You knocked on the door and
had a sketch like the deal,
how you were going to kick him and run
into the weeds and go right to the coke
dealers house. Like I had a plan.
We had done it so many times,
but I had to keep getting different
partners because I couldn't hit Freddie.
All I could do was tackle them.
I was good at tackling them and then
we want to go down and have my friend
kicked him a few times. It just fucking
horrible, but when you're 16 Joe,
what the fuck though? You've got
to have a good time. You know
you're not going to kick study Freddy
where you're going to kick Jesus Christ.
You're so right about the numbers.
My grandmother loved.
That's big Italian big and this is silly.
And then they have dreams and dreams.
The vesper came from them
in the middle of the night.
It's my grandma told him to play six 44.
Yup.
My grandmother would never
not shut the fuck up about it.
And then they give you a
little note and they fucking,
and this is psyllium is
almost as bad as the Cubans.
The old school, she's silly and are
very stupid. Stitious with the eyes.
They make those fucking soups with the
eye and shit. And I had fucking, I had,
I had to seal ends in my neighborhood
that I'm still very tight with.
I still talk to her a lot,
but even the way they spoke
Italian schedule like the way they,
the ferociousness and they're fucking
language cause they got beat up for years.
The history assists. Lee's a very
fucking sad one, but it's so, uh,
you know, there's that expression.
Never feel Rome. The snakes lot,
the snake lies coiled and a golden nugget.
The snake,
Laos called and Naples,
you know,
nobody ever gave Cecily respect that we're
like the best fucking child. You know,
the kids I grew up with have
blonde hair and blue eyes,
which really puts in doubt.
You know,
other people say that the
Moore's conquered sizzling
and raped them and shit.
And we discussed it to the night of the
vespers when all the men got up and cut
that big off and shit.
That's why it's happened.
If you look it up on Wikipedia at night
of a thousand vespers or something,
look it up guys. Let's get this
fax right. If a thousand vests,
s'mores with torturing the Sicilians in
the 1400 tortured and 15 hundreds and
they were fucking raping that women.
And One night the Sicilians got together
and fucking couldn't take it no more.
And they got up and I know one night
and they killed these mother fuckers,
but they cut that Dick's off and
shoved them in the fucking mouth.
And that's why it Sicilians are very
sensitive when it comes to the issue of
rape. They can't, they can't because
it's in their DNA. Like they can't,
they got raped. They got slaughtered.
It's an that fucking thing.
These Moore's the Moore's or who like
crazy black people from Africa that
fucking left age. I think they
offer map. Yeah. That's from Africa.
The Moore's guys we know is the whole
premise of that scene and I'm a true
romance.
The Sicilian vespers,
the name given to successful rebellion
on the island of Sicily that broke out in
the Easter of 1282 against the rule.
The French Capetian King Charles
the first, yeah, it was wrong.
Who had ruled the king of Sicily
since 1266 within six weeks,
3000 French men and women
were slain by the rebels,
the rebels and the government of King
Charles lost control of the island.
It was the beginning of the
war of the Sicilian vespers.
Hmm. Like get to go down,
but it got people [inaudible]. Once you
get to the Moise Sicilian or breast,
that's a fucked up country.
That's like Cuba.
So they fucking sac that belief
in the Catholicism religion,
but a little more like most
people. That's my people. Yeah. No,
a little more than most people.
They really believe and they put them a
Luke on yet and I hope you fucking die.
They spit on themselves.
You know,
my mom couldn't say cancer without
spitting on herself. What does,
somebody would say cancer.
My mom will,
I do it all the time now. People
talking about cancer, about myself,
I spend on myself and so weird.
That was my grandmother.
My grandmother was so crazy,
man.
My grandmother went to jail because she
wouldn't write out the mom because she
was running numbers. My grandmother
was running numbers. We,
she went to Jeff for six months.
We'd always be like, where's grandma?
She's with an aunt Annie. Where's
grandma? She's with at marine like,
why isn't she with Amory?
Like doesn't make any sense.
Then one day when I was like 20 they told
me, Greg, you know, grandma was in jail,
right? And I was like,
what? She was crazy.
She had a monkey named Chichi.
The monkey lived in the attic.
My grandmother was off the charts crazy.
She was very artistic
and a Chichi fucking hated
everybody except my grandma.
My grandma would feed this monkey gum,
the gum,
the monkey would take a stick of gum,
unwrapped the gum.
Let me start chewing gum in front of you.
The monkey knew that it was gum.
It didn't try to eat.
It just chewed
it like you would chew gum. The monkey
would sit there and chew fucking gum.
He would eat. He would peel
bananas in front of you to
be, you have come near him.
When he was with her,
he will bite your fucking face like no
one could come near Cigi she was the only
one, so there's like crazy lady had a
monkey and her base or in her attic.
So we would come over to hang out. My
Grandmother, she'd make homemade pasta.
They would make homemade sauce from
the tomatoes that my grandfather grew,
those jersey beef, steak,
tomatoes. He always had a garden.
My grandfather always had.
He always had a big fucking
fenced in garden in his back,
like he was growing all kinds of things.
He would tell you how to grow and
he was very meticulous about it.
Like he was really invested in this
garden and they would take the tomatoes,
they would make fresh tomato sauce.
My grandmother would make fresh homemade
pasta. It was fucking sensational.
The food was sensational.
My,
my grandmother's homemade pasta has a
taste that liked to this day I don't,
I don't think I've ever experienced
it anywhere else before.
Cause you can get really good
homemade pasta at a restaurant.
You can get really good homemade pasta,
you know, in a nice place or some,
some folks know how to make it.
But when you're getting it from someone
who's like literally making it in the
same way that the,
the original immigrants,
it's very different than
the way Italians make it.
The Italians in North America have
a very different style of, of food,
of cooking with red sauce.
You're like, that's not as,
that was not as popular in
Italy is it wasn't miracle.
All this pasta and meatballs,
Spaghetti and meatballs,
these are American Italian dishes and
my grandmother was a master at those.
Oh my God.
She would make these fucking meatballs.
You would walk in the house
and they'd be cooking.
You'd hear the crackling and the you like,
good fucking Lord.
She would cook them on a frying Pan,
just get these motherfuckers perfect and
crackling and then she would cook them
in the sauce for hours,
had sausage, blip, blip,
blip, just simmering for hours. She would
check it, stick a wooden spoon near him,
put that fucking live right
back on and walk away.
She knew when it was done and you
would have this fucking Italian food.
It was just so ridiculous, so ridiculous,
but it's, they've been Americanized,
but if you go to some homes I got,
there was a hole in my neighborhood
who were very nice people and the
grandmother always cooked and
her dishes were never red sauce.
There were always based with
pasta with beans, which I love.
I love teaching pasta. I love
Pasta for Zul at Spanish. Lissa,
there's no better mail for you as a
health thing. I don't give a fuck.
'Em some people say Pasta,
a zoo and some fast because
they would go to olive garden.
But what is the right way to say, oh
no, I don't know because my credit,
my family always said
[inaudible] foster for a zoo.
But what is positive as Jolie?
That's the same thing.
You don't know how it breaks it a dialect.
It's got that stuff and it's not spinach.
If something else is there,
the different dishes. Uh, I'm
not, it's the same dish. Gyro,
Euro. Honestly, I think it's everybody
has it.
You know,
somebody possibles rule is completely
different than if you go to whole foods.
It's completely different than when
I go to my friends and jerseys.
It's a thicker stock.
It's got the spinach with uh,
with the beans and the little fucking
pastas in it and they freeze it.
And that's where the strength comes in.
It's like get stronger and
stronger and that garlic,
and in the winter that's what they
offer you. But that's port map. See,
Italians were very poor,
so all the dishes are based around really
potato beans and pasta and bread and
bread.
Bread was big.
My grandfather used to go to this bread
store that was a bakery that was down
the block. We would walk down
the block on North Ninth Street.
We'd go about two blocks down and we
walk into this old school Italian bakery
that, you know, it's since
1926 I'm shelling the on the,
on the sign and you would get basically
the same kind of bread every day.
And it's sensational.
Had fucking real Italian bread
from New York, New Jersey,
like that area from the immigrants.
Holy Shit was that good.
And he wasn't just get bread brown cross
got that motherfucker with a serrated
knife and it's just so,
it's just delicious.
Like you don't get bread like
that out here for some reason.
And if it was a good day to
motherfuck was making separately,
oh what kind of them in the bag would
leak on the sugar and on the way home
you'll be inhaling bread and fucking
Zappa. Lee's and nobody gained a pound.
Nobody was allergic to gluten.
It was not people rub example is on their
fucking faces cause I was one of them.
Let me tell you what, what
meal I discovered like at
12 and the Italian house.
Fucking Cannoli, because from
Hoboken Karma, mine would
go to Hoboken and pick up,
I know he's a guy would only make 16 of
them on Fridays. So you had an older guy.
He only gave me for that type
of shit. Like that family.
It was that type of shit.
Hoboken's very Italian.
What happened to Hoboken was like
anywhere else and we don't want to live in
Hoboken no more. We're going to
move to, you know, Jersey City.
So all those areas got to
taste the whole booklet.
But all of that northern New Jersey Shit,
that's all whole boat.
And at the end of the fucking day,
those are years and years of Italians
that were in Hoboken, you know,
working on the trains and all that
shit. You know, Hoboken, when we,
if you ever saw Hoboken in the
eighties it was a fucking die.
You would go to fourth street, all
that shit. You get mugged on it.
They were fucking around when Bob Dubois
and all those guys are Mondo a rebus.
We're running fucking
basketball down there. You went.
I used to take a bus to Hoboken
to play basketball and pro.
You had a guard that fucking ball.
You gotta Watch your hooded sweatshirt.
They would jack your shit though.
But I knew the benders down there and
I used to go down and I used to go to a
place down there that
had that bread the point,
because it's not round that that's
the shit you see now. I see it.
At times it would get round. Loves to,
Oh my God, at the top of the witch's hat,
take that mother fuck off and put a,
put a piece of hotel Bob Butler in
that mother fucker and let it come out.
Good googling you.
Feel your heartbeat now.
And this is appellee's now that
you'll never see that again.
I think that there's still parts of the
city and somebody, one of those guys,
I think Anthony Bordain went to Brooklyn
a few weeks ago and he went to one of
those places that had Zappa.
He's somebody.
It Bordain went into this one.
There's like a,
an Italian Deli that serves lunch.
They'll serve like pasta with red sauce
and a meatball and the place has been
under the same family's ownership since
the 18 hundreds some crazy like that.
And this guy who was running it was a
little boy. He's a, he's an old man.
He was a little boy when he started
working there and so Bordain she's showing
these pictures of him and he's old school,
black and white pictures of him in this
place and now hearing is running it.
It's crazy.
Like those,
that's like a direct connection to the
people that came over on those boats.
That's, that's wild shit man. I don't
think about it too much, but when I do,
my grandparents were both
born in other countries.
They were both born in Italy and
my grandfather on my father's side,
I was born in Ireland. My grandmother
on my father's side was born in Italy.
They were all immigrants,
all of them.
They all came over in a
wave and the twenties and
thirties and they survived the
fucking great depression dev or
a different kind of human being.
There are different kinds of human beings
then we are today so much show the,
the metamorphosis of the human race from
the time that people came over on boats
to what we are today. It's,
it's bananas. I mean it's,
it's almost like one of the
biggest leaps of, of like,
of like a culture changing.
I'm going to wrap it away like the human
beings have today in comparison to the
human beings have, you know, naming to
[inaudible] number a hundred years ago,
you know,
cause my grandparents,
it's basically almost a hundred years
before they came over here. It's crazy.
That's a crazy world.
They lived in Joey,
they didn't even have a video of
what the United States look like.
And they had the balls to get in the
boat with kids and come across the ocean.
No, it was supposed to be a
better life. And it was, you know,
people don't know is an episode of
Sopranos when he explains how, uh,
they all came to a neighborhood,
remember there's a beautiful episode.
And he goes, oh, when they
tried to buy the eggs member,
they tried to buy the store where they
had eggs on the corner. And he goes,
let me tell you something.
He goes, we came here,
my family came in 80 years ago and
we all moved to a neighborhood.
That's what families did show all
the Rogan's would live on third,
every Rogan cousin, you know, they
weren't all Rogan's, uh, whatever.
They are regular on all those.
They will all know my,
my grandfather's name was rogue, rogue.
And so they all moved into an area.
And then when they got,
when he said that goes down,
they went up to get the Gulch.
He goes and they all went to
Broomfield and he goes, you know,
is the only place in the neighborhood
that you could still go and get chicken
eggs, not those fucking supermarket eggs.
He goes, I can't sell it ticket. And it,
and it was all those neighbors, whether
it's whole book and uh, Brooklyn get
all those Canarsie,
those Italian people came over,
they live nine to one apartment,
you know, and you know,
what really saddens you that those people
that came over and never got to see
the fruits of their labor,
they never got to see what their great
grandson did or what do you know what I'm
saying? Like in a way,
yeah, but they did. I mean,
I think they got to see the world change.
You know,
anybody that came over from the
1920s and went through World War II,
you've got to see some goddamn
crazy changing the world. You know?
And I think back then to a greater
sense that the good guys won. You know,
right now the lines kind of blurry the
United States back in the 1940s after we
won World War Two and
it was over and they ha,
they show people like
kissing in the streets.
You're not going to see that shit again.
That's,
we don't have the same
enthusiasm about wars.
They did that because back then they
really thought there was good guys and bad
guys. It was real simple.
There was Nazis back then.
There was kamikaze is back then.
It was crazy method up.
Japanese dudes were flying planes into
fucking boats. They attacked Pearl Harbor.
They get, they didn't give
a fuck. This was a dangerous
time. So when the, when the,
when Japan won,
when Japan signed and after
they bombed Hiroshima, Nagasaki,
when they eliminated those fucking cities
and Japan signed the trust agreement
or whatever the fuck it was,
that was everybody was, it
was over. Like we had one,
like people were happy as fuck back then.
So they went through that,
which is a pretty crazy time.
They went from the time of no movies
to movies. That's a crazy time.
They went to see movies.
They like one of the first,
well their generation was
the first have televisions.
Like he saw TV for the first time
when there was no TV before them.
No one had ever had TV before.
When people return home from World War
Two where they treated the way when
people came back from Vietnam?
No,
I told him he would spit on totally your
fucking baby killer and all that shit.
That fucking stinks.
Start when was it fucking good to go
to the airport after a war and spit at
people went over there.
You have a fucking opinion about somebody
who went over there and actually put
his life up,
whether he knew what not.
What the fuck is going on in
your 18 fucking years old?
I think when World War Two didn't they
take give you a dirty fucking five
minutes. Give a fuck. Right. A World
War One. I think those fucking whores,
I don't know if anybody really did
spit on anybody in calm baby killers.
They did some and deserves all the
hippies and all that shit. There was a,
that was a part of the thing that someone
refuted about the Chris Kyle Story
Cause Chris Kyle said
that that happened to him.
Someone calling him a baby killer and
he was saying that this is all like what
he's doing. He's repeating something
that someone else had. Man,
I need to look into it more.
But for sure they were treated like a
lot of people thought the Vietnam War was
a bad idea.
They didn't think it was the same as
the way they thought of World War II,
World War II. It was like a war that
everybody kind of agreed how to happen.
There was a crazy guy in Germany that
was taken over the world and he was
killing Jews. He killed millions of
fucking people. Then there was a Japanese,
they were in on it together.
Somehow mean didn't even make any sense.
They don't even speak the same language.
They're in cahoots.
So it was the Japanese and then there was
the fucking Americans and the Russians
were involved and like fucking Christ.
So when that was over,
those people would experience some
gigantic change. They felt like,
probably made sense that
they came over here.
They came over to the baddest
fucking team ever, you know,
and everybody was like a part of it.
When when you see that celebration,
everybody's kissing in the streets and
everything after the Japanese surrendered.
That's a,
that's a powerful,
iconic slice of like that embodies like
what that time meant to a lot of people.
That shit doesn't happen now.
So they,
I think they experienced
a lot of pretty cool shit.
They experienced a lot of God damn change
and the what we're living right now,
I mean there's an amazing
as this world is right now,
if we keep going at the same rate,
I think a hundred years from now people
are going to look back at this time.
I go, look at these silly fucks. God Damn,
these people were suffering that
he's still got colds. You know,
they still had to worry about losing
weight. They still had to worry about,
you know, getting enough sleep. Like
they were worried about their health.
Like these poor fuckers, if they
got the flu, they had to stay home.
Like this is going to be some
shit a hundred years from now.
It's going to just fix everything.
Anytime anything's wrong.
There's not going to be, there's not
going to be more health concerns.
Our concern is going to be making sure
that we don't have too many people on the
earth. That's going to be our number
one concern in like a hundred years,
but it's the things that we
look at now and we think, God,
I couldn't imagine living like they lived
in 1920s fuck that little stupid ass
TV.
The little tiny as black and white TV.
That was the size of a laptop and it was
in a cabinet that looked like a fucking
gun safe.
You remember those stupid things?
Giant ass cabinets with his little stupid
screen that was black and white and a
record player on top and it
would lift the whole thing.
We'll lift up on top and he had all the
speakers on the TV in the middle with
the controls over here that you had to
lift up and over here was directed play,
so we had a switch TV to stereo and then
the speakers were over here and they
both came and Jesus.
Those things are cool.
That's what I watched superman
on for my first time as a kid.
I remember watching it
on TV on one of those,
I watch a lot of fucking Yankee Games
and my grandfather's and you don't do it,
dude. When the TV would go bad,
they'd put a smaller TV on top of it.
They didn't want to get rid of
the cabinet, so cause the cabinet,
it was so nice and then TV
started becoming smaller.
They became like a plastic box,
like a shitty kind of plastic box.
I take that shitty plastic box,
put it right on top of the other
fucking teeth like everybody did that.
Everybody had a TV on
top of the broken TV.
My mom put a TV on top of [inaudible].
She could see the mets and
the Yankees at the same time.
That's how my mom does that.
Cuba, they loved that baseball,
she loved the beds,
put sewer love like what we was
playing the Yankees or whatever.
So she was the original sports
bar at the house, at your house,
but she was the original sport
where you go to a sports bar,
you're overwhelmed by the amount of
different games that are going on at once,
but that will show,
remember the fights I saw at a
bar like at her bar I saw it was,
I got an education that I don't remember.
Lot of those fights even have to tell me,
but I saw all the great fights that
were on ABC sports center at that bar.
When they fight in the afternoons,
four 30 in the afternoons on Saturday,
I still remember this is how fucking old
guy am I did a scam for with these Jews
with side learns, his fucking
Jew in Jersey where he, for
years he used to bug me.
Listen,
if you ever need any money,
we exclude somebody and when
he would do is in the daytime,
he'd go around and look for holes and
then consistency in supermarkets and shit
and he set up the whole thing for you.
All you have to do is fall.
God, it's so crazy. The
guy was a genius.
They paid them,
the major colleges and some pro football
teams paid him and he would fly out and
scout other teams. That's how much
of a genius he was. He was, he was,
what do you call those people are not
dunks. And he always says those people,
they're good at. They're only good at one
thing. Idiot savant. He would, I mean,
he was missing a tooth. His shorts
had piano. He looked in a garage.
Okay, because every dollar he spent was
it the generate gamma. Oh, but that's,
that's what he did. He went around in
the daytime looking for holes and shit,
and he's like, wait, what do you
want? What do you need? Plenty. Geez,
I'll make it 20 it.
When we go to the supermarket,
I don't knock over the apple sauce.
You fall down and stayed down
to like give you the nod. Right?
You start yelling and screaming. Then you
pass out. And when the lady comes over,
he had the whole scan.
The next day he picked you up.
He took it to the attorney's office.
He took it to the hospital,
he took it to the chiropractor's office.
He took it to everywhere you had a beat.
And his philosophy is he got you
with as many doctors as he could.
You got to quit your job,
you got to quit your day job because
all he did was make appointments for you
and everybody was in on the scan.
So when his world,
the more the higher your doctor bills,
you got 10 times that Shaviah doctor
bills are like fucking or something like
that.
If your doctor bills were half a million,
he could get you a hundred
thousand 200,000 you know,
like if you lost a finger,
he had the home menu or you need 60,000
give me a finger, you know, fuck it.
Let's lose a finger on the top and
shit like that. He was that crazy. Wow.
So I had to go to a chiropractor and
he tells me that's how he sold it.
You want to make money,
you got to punch in.
So you've got to go to all those doctors
every day and take the treatment.
And the doctors have to
give you the treatment even
though they know it's a scam,
they're rent on it. So that I
remember going to the chiropractor,
he would put those laser beams on me,
those pads and my back and just walk
out of the room and then come back.
But I went up there the day,
boom. Mcne killed the Korean guy.
It was on wide world of sports. I'm a
Saturday afternoon and I had none of that.
It was like time stopped.
Like the phone was ringing
at the chiropractor's office
and nobody was Hansard.
That's how much of an
intense fight this was.
Like the people came out from behind
the counter and it was on regular TV.
I think Fox had just come in.
Fox wasn't still around.
I don't think it was around, you know,
there was like ABC wide world of sports,
83 83 one year to Fox come around.
It was when I was in high school.
So that was in high school.
They had a,
the Simpsons and America's most wanted,
so 88 86 no shit.
I was out of high school.
Wow. So it must've been when I
was still living at home. This,
I remember the Simpsons.
I mean that was when it didn't
Fox start with the Simpsons,
the Tracey Ullman show. When did
the Simpsons since 1989, Tracy,
all men had the Simpsons
are in it. It was, uh,
like really horrible animation
in the Tracey Ullman show.
Remember the Simpsons looked all weird
and they all look messed up and I don't
really remember my,
that, my memory of that.
It's foggy shit.
But I do remember watching those fights
on ABC wide world of sports. You know,
they had a,
NBC had boxing on a Friday night,
recently pit world
champion or maybe Saturday,
but a Adrian Broner versus a John Molina.
And then they had,
um, what's the other fight? Uh,
Keith Thurman Versus um,
Robert Carrera, good fights,
but they went the distance.
Bolton,
what the distance when you watching
boxing on regular TV? It feels weird.
I was like, Whoa, it's box on TV again.
Like it's been off of regular
TV for a long ass time.
I think that, uh, that's one
show they should bring back.
I think that was my first discovery
channel was wild world of sports.
That was one of the most interesting
shows when I was growing up because you
didn't know what you were going to watch.
Sometimes I don't think wide world of
sports with lasted a bar that I like or
even then because every once in a while
they to have like ballet from China.
Hong Kong people go ape shit.
I still remember watching Arron banks,
uh, karate championships. I'm
wild world of sports as a kid.
I used to go to the garden
to watch this. Uh, but uh,
his big closer was the guy who they put
a mirror in front of and they'd shoot at
them when they're 22 and he'd put a
mouthpiece in his mouth and he catched the
bullet.
Come on you guys.
The guys doing the trick
though, right? I listen.
I'd love to fucking tell you know, I think
I'm pretty sure that's a fucking jerk.
He catches it and then he spits the bullet
on the frying pan and smoke comes out
of the fucking bullet. I don't know.
You know, but that was his main thing.
It's some sort of, how do
you practice? I mean that,
that was what I always wanted to know.
What the fuck do they have a
practice here? Eat Bullets.
Who's going to let you
come over and you shoot.
I don't want to 22 it's taught
by throwing grapes in his mouth.
Are you fucking crazy? A great bit
of bullets. Two different bodies.
But you got to start slow. Oh my God.
That's how I used to figure it out.
Nobody could just just do it one time.
You got to practice that shit and
tell the timing and fucking Pam and
no to twist. And that's a carny trick.
And if they did do it,
there's gotta be some bodies involved.
Like we got to do a documentary on them,
whoever the bodies of the people tried
to catch bullets with their teeth.
Like let's not try the shotgun this time.
It's just try regular gun
or a BB gun or something.
Well they definitely have killed people
accidentally and those like stupid like
magic tricks, stunts. It's definitely
happened. It's definitely happened.
I know I've read it.
I've read stories about people
dying doing crazy magic experiments.
When you try to like really
push the limits, you got a
lot of variables involved.
One could go wrong. Next thing
you know you're fake gun. Like,
like when Brandon lead died,
he died on a set of a movie in a special
effects scene. They shot him with a,
a fake gun,
a gun with blanks.
But there was some piece of a shell or
something that was still in the chamber,
that gun and that shot into him.
You know,
that was what the triads got them.
Do you think so? You really do.
You know those people, that Sicilian
dog. Listen, you don't want,
I'm going to kill you and your fucking
son. They did it. That's what it is.
Cause I had heard that he died,
that Bruce Lee died from some sort of an
allergic reaction to a drug or listen,
he,
he was doing,
he did three or four movies with
these fucking have fucking salesman.
They invested $6,000 and they fucking
went to the bank and said they made
millions. Nobody knows how
much enter the Dragon, man.
Nobody knows it's 42 years and correct.
80 90 it's 42 years and see what
that made worldwide the first week.
You know what I mean? Fucking copies.
Enter the dragon are not there.
That's Raymond Chow after fucking Raymond
chowder the business with the studios.
Amen. Enter the Dragon. I don't know if
he, it was Raymond Chow, the other guy,
sterling silhouette or one of those
fucking guys. After Bruce Lee die,
there's a Raymond child really fucking
blew up and he was a heroin fucking guy
through him. He ended up, he ended up,
what are your own child? Child stood.
What was the name of Ron? Ron
Chow. Run one child studios.
They ended up doing Charles Bronson
movies and Clint Eastwood Movies and Shit.
They gave him a color. The action
somewhere. Another. Wow. This is a,
this is crazy. It says he died
from a cerebral edema. Right?
Some Chinese guy could tell you anything.
Listen, my father died of a cocaine,
heroin overdose of heroin overdose.
They told me he died of a heart
attack and then never signed the death
certificate.
Where's that doctor today?
I guarantee you got hit by a bus two
weeks fucking later after they signed that
cerebral Herbert told,
but that guy died two weeks later
and a fucking building fire.
He could go out of the fucking elevator.
This is what it says here, Ron,
at the time, I mean obviously when
someone's writing something in Wikipedia,
decades after the fact,
who knows?
Who knows how much they went to some
chicks house off the bat, he was adultery.
They paid that chick to bring them over
and that's what they fucking whacked
them.
It says around the time of Lee's death,
numerous rumors appeared in the media at
least iconic status and unlikely demise
fed many wild rumors and theories.
These include murder involving the triads
and it's opposed as a curse on him and
his family.
That's all I tell you.
What the fuck we can get used.
Electrical muscular stimulation that
may have exacerbated or resulted in his
condition. That doesn't make any sense.
So what they're saying is his conclusion.
David, a tier a forensic scientist, uh,
recommended by Scotland Yard
who'd overseeing a thousand
autopsies was assigned
to the case.
His conclusion was death by misadventure
caused by an acute cerebral edema to a
reaction,
uh,
to compounds present in the
combination medication equip Jessic.
I don't know what that shit is.
Pain relieved rule for a
headache or something like that.
So all this side kicks he took to the
fucking head and all the aspirins,
he took an China.
It never affected them until that fucking
night when he went to madame choose
fucking house.
I mean,
he died with his Stan because
he was actually in bed with
her. He was in her bed.
I mean, a bunch of stories change to make
them look bad at the end when he left,
uh, those people that do enter the dragon,
he pissed off a lot of people. Man.
He was making them a lot of
fucking money. Well, you know what?
Apparently he was already having seizures.
There was a doctor,
a neurosurgeon who treated a Bruce Lee
during his first seizure in May of 1973
he was eating hash to fucking
come down from the pain.
He was one of the first people that
figured out that has sheets was what's,
what's Advil when you'd take
it? What's Advil? Ibuprofen.
What's the really duty beside
killed playing? What's, see,
it's called a nonsteroidal
antiinflammatory hash is
and anti inflammatory.
That is marijuana.
So Bruce Lee figured it out first.
Bruce Lee used to eat hash after fucking
working out to, to reduce the thing.
He would've died a long fucking,
he was brain wouldn't swallow.
Long time ago that guy
died and the height guys,
nobody right now.
Right now there's not too many
people to remember the day he died.
I've been first role and nobody even
heard the day he died because news didn't
travel that fast.
There was no internet.
We got it like two days
later that he died.
And I remember half of Americans walking
around fucking wounded and that was one
of those people. And I didn't believe
it because he was fucking healthy shit.
He was flying through the air.
He was making it fucking happened,
but he went back to China and God knows
what they did to him over that dog,
and we'll never know. Here's
a, a preliminary appearance.
This is really interesting of doctor
preliminary opinion of Doctor Peter Woo.
The neurosurgeon who treated lead during
his first seizure was that the cause of
death should have been
attributed to either a reaction
to cannabis or equal just
sick cannabis like his fucking this
is that, you know, it's bullshit.
His doctor is telling them
that it might've been,
we'd very potent Nepali
Hash Killed Bruce Lee.
He was a Hashtag [inaudible]
he discovered it first. Listen,
they used to be cookies at Kush
mark that whatever you wait,
whatever you weight
during the week was good.
But when he used to have these cookies
that were oatmeal in fuse would hash
shore. And guys, that was
when I first started my diet,
when I was 418 pounds and I couldn't walk
how sore and my ankles and I would eat
two of those hash cookies and the next
day my ankles would be like a fucking
pick the fucking hash
with reduce everything.
I wouldn't even feel it bent over rows.
Nothing.
My Back Hash is the best.
It's amazing.
And he was fucked up Joey.
Okay. This is a, this is a fact,
he had a ruptured disc in his back
that someone had given them. Yeah.
But this is one of the reasons why he
was taking all kinds of different shit to
try to deal with the uh, with the
pain. And He'd already had seizures.
So he had seizures.
He had a ruptured disc in his back
and he was getting medicated. Wayne,
the seizure they talking
about is the shit.
They tried to throw it into the dryer and
the biography about him cause he would
go away.
Like he would go away,
like he would go away and get
up to say Jo Jo Jo, oh sorry.
But the doctor said it's saying seizure.
It says neurosurgeon treated
him for his first seizure.
It's the same guy that says that pot
might've killed them too though I don't
believe nothing and I love Chinese people
and I loved the theories and stuff.
You just think they killed him, Huh?
They killed him. They killed that.
Chuck Norris said that his death was
a reaction between the muscle relaxant
medication that had been taken
since 1968 for rupture disc,
so he was taking that the ruptured disc
shit for a long time because he died in
[inaudible] 73 he's still alive, but he's
not getting kicked in the head either.
He switches. How many times do you think
he fell downstairs? Come on Joe Rogan.
How many times you think Keith
Richards fell on the thing?
You think you look like that?
Because he seems like the type of dude
that would be able to figure it out
correctly. This fucking guy
went into, listen, Joe Rogan,
when you fucking with that type of
environment, you fuck with them.
You could kill their mother and they don't
give a fuck when you hit their pocket.
They don't deal with that shit.
They Chinese listen,
the mafia concept was stolen
from the triads. There's still,
they're the smartest guys in the world.
They still,
they're probably at war with
the government from who's
bringing the heroin and
they brought heroin in. Fee is
not one DEA case, not one da case.
And go talking mole lane for heroin as
ever been caught on us from with genius
geniuses. They pay everybody. These
guys, when it comes to that paper,
they don't fuck around.
In 1985,
they got sick and tired of giving the
mafia pounds a hand on a for $50,000.
The Mafia was cut at 10 times making a
half a million and a $50,000 investment.
They got sick and tired. The Chinese go
to go to fucking go to fucking, uh, uh,
whatever. Now see how small little Italy
is. Who Do you think it took him from?
The Chinese. They don't fuck around
dog. They don't fuck around that.
I don't like that.
That's still out there.
There's motherfucker
when you go to Wyoming,
why is there a Chinese restaurant that
you think Chinese people like Wyoming,
all this state after the fucking hat,
the railroads,
and then they got cutting on the fucking
heroin through it. I think that everyone
gets to Wyoming. So fucking white
people and envelopes. Fuck, no,
it's those Chinese people.
I don't really believe that that's a joke.
But uh, I, I, when I was a kid, I
heard a lot of stuff about the Chinese.
I don't want, I don't like to
believe crazy conspiracy theories,
but if I was going to believe anyone,
I would believe that the Chinese mob
would kill you if you somehow or another
fuck the amount of money. I mean, that's,
that's one that seems like, let's go.
All right. They made him famous too,
right? I mean, he wasn't famous for,
for those movies. He was famous dog.
By the time he hit Chinese connection,
I still remember the two hand punch.
The two hand punching the school
was down the fucking commercial.
We're watching happy days.
Bitch was sitting around 20 fucking
Puerto Rican kids wear robes on at a
Catholic school, pajamas on and
ready to go to bed and awesome.
They go this Friday coming through
the movie through the play,
the trailer with Chinese connection.
Jamie play the fucking trailer.
It's a trailer.
Play the fucking trail.
You've got to see the one
from the French connection.
You would have to see the
one from the mechanic. Ooh,
Ooh,
Ooh.
Hard times has a phenomenal trailer.
Hard times have they had prayers,
but it was the voice,
the tone of his voice.
It was the voice before this
voice and he was a little mean.
I got type of guy say then
play the children's hours,
but I still remember the best trail
of all time is the French connection.
Why they're shooting him in the bath as
he's going up to train and gene Hackman
goes freeze.
It's pop by and shoots him in the back
of me and they locked it and it said
filmed in New York where it happened.
Look at the fucking look.
A trailer for Chinese collection is shit.
[inaudible].
Yup.
Wow.
Bruce Lee is the real
superstar and the week of his,
what do you do if you excite
you right now? Watch this.
What do you do if you're
a bigot? Bam, Bam,
Bam. Nobody can tell you right here. What
do you do when you're ready? You'll move.
Fuck Buffy for whitetail.
What's this bliss.
You lose your fucking mind. Fuck
God. Zillow. Plumbing's would,
this was the first police would he went
back to the time they left his role in
people to the fucking air with each hand.
Look at this.
This was a trailer is when they
killed his teacher. Look at them.
That's the opening. Look at it. Look at
young. This is a movie you have to watch.
This is one of the greatest
movies of all time.
He had fucking Steve Mcqueen and his,
he robbed the phone down of what?
The doe
all dub.
That wasn't even his voice because
they didn't like the way he talked.
Look at this guy.
He kills this motherfucker.
Hags that's how angry
he wasn't this movie,
so Nah, don't dump. Don't, oops.
Sounds like Bobby. Like watched it. This
one. He made them meet the guidelines.
This is
tremendous,
but down attack them.
Everybody wanted to be Bruce.
He stopped the new judge in this movie.
Oh you didn't bust the mind and fist of
fury, which became Chinese connection.
He busted a mountain. This one. That's
when he made them meet the fucking glass.
That's when he hung to the people.
That's when he killed the first Russian.
Come on now who fucking
thing get dealing with?
He does a move and that movie dog
that is so sensational. His anger,
you know he started hanging motherfuckers,
nobody be hanging.
That's Clint Eastwood Type Shit and hang
them high and we got to check the dates.
Maybe Clint would rob them.
Of course he did.
This is the harvest party
was hanging people back then.
Do you bring the Chinese fucking people
had a had a chick to the fucking drama
to see if they got the other trailer cause
see if they got the other really good
trailer thing. Notice how he has to
make out with a Chinese check too.
Would they have movies back then were
Chinese guy would make out with a white
girl on film. Did they have movies
like that back then? I don't know what,
enter the Dragon. Jimmy Lee. Fuck the
Chinese church, right? James. James Kelly.
What was his name was Jim Kelly.
Jim Kelly. Jim Kelly fucked.
I remember he could hit like eight of them
sent to his room. John Sax at the Wig.
Is there another team? I remember
Chuck Norris versus Bruce Lee. Yeah.
Let's watch that real quick. That's,
that's sensational. That's, yeah.
See if he could find Chuck Norris
versus Bruce Lee came on HBO and my head
almost.
I made my mother get me Hbo on the
roof to came on because the chicks ran
through the jungles with tits group tube
is cousins with Kentucky Fried Movie.
What is it? I've never even heard of it.
I can take a free movie. No, the group,
the groove tube is move to prove tube is
Saturday night live. Before Sinai lie,
they made two movies called the Groove
Tube and Kentucky Fried Chicken,
Kentucky Fried Moving Kentucky, Kentucky.
If I move, oh shit. Look at this.
This is the game though. That's
the game. God Damn. Look,
Chuck Norris taken off his black belt.
Look how young he is.
Okay,
and Bruce Lee, this is a gay porn. Look
how slowly they are on the roving. Oh,
this is the game.
And look at how we look at Charles Norris.
Chuck Norris is chest. Charles
Norris. Look at his chest.
It's all Harry and shits before dude's
figured out shaving your chest and when
you see this,
and then you don't like wrestling,
what do you think the big differences
like you know the movie mother fucker.
That's it. That's all you're going to
see us play. This was Brian. This was,
look, I'll rip Bruce. This was
something that you cannot imagine.
This was every nerd had a hero.
Every immigrant out here, bro.
Everybody had a hero. They'll give a
kitten. Look at the fucking kitten.
Everybody had that place. Has a million
cats on there. The Roman Colosseum though.
Look what he's warming up.
They're both warming up.
They're doing cod a warm up for the fight.
We're looking at each other.
This is the craziest ones.
I've seen tremendous shit, man.
America has to put these four on and
realize why stop [inaudible] I'm Bruce Lee
changed my life. You only saw one
fucking movie. You got to see all four.
Forget the game of debt with Kareem
Abdul Jabbar. That's a harvest show.
Just watch this one. Look at this.
That's what he does when he me out.
It's just one of the fight
starts looking at him dog.
He had like 6% body fat at this time.
This guy wasn't gonna die.
Joe Rogan. People like this don't die.
Don't fucking insult me. He didn't die.
They killed this poor little kid.
But this is really fascinating.
I've never seen a movie that I recall
were two guys warmed up like this before a
fight.
But that's,
but this is fascinating how they
just don't even look at each other.
They move away.
They go in their own little fucking world
for awhile and they meet in the center
like these are, this is a different
thing than a fight in a movie. You know
I,
this is two guys agreeing.
We have to find out who's the baddest
mother fucker alive. You know,
they agree to do it the right way.
Everybody warms up.
Bruce Lee catches a good sweat, so
it was chuck. This is crazy shit man.
I forgot how crazy this is a,
this is the beginning guys. Well,
Joe and I talked about the movies in
1973 you really want to watch this shit
today. Go ahead. But
this is where it starts.
This is where all these movies are stolen
from and they can't even steal them.
They don't know why they even did this.
Okay?
Bruce Lee is getting into his fighting
stance. You're the cap. Bam, Bam, Bam.
Yeah.
The bolts were on front leg roundhouse
kicks to open up with in front leg
sidekicks.
Okay.
No one's hit anybody that
block and everything. Oh,
Chuck Norris scores or the wheel
kick to the face and smiles.
He doesn't even follow up. He said,
gentlemen, no ground and pound, right.
Oh Shit. Chuck is putting a
beating on him. Oh my goodness. Oh,
Bruce Lee grabbed the god damn chest hair.
It's not fair.
It's rude is this is also the beginning
of tank pseudo when chuck Norris split
from tank taekwondo and he could
recreate this shit. Really? Yeah.
He's a tank pseudo guy. Yeah,
but he, I don't think he created,
well supposedly he had his, his style.
I mean it was definitely a style,
but it existed before, so they did
two different tanks who dose, right.
This tank Sudo Su bog doll and
I think he went the other way.
There's a superbug Dole that they all,
they all started together but he
went the other way. Yeah. Tanks.
You don't have a little bit
of grappling in it. Yes.
They had more grappling it then talk
to doe did they had like some risks,
locks and joint locks and stuff.
Hey, we go. So he gets his timing.
He starts fucking jumping up and
down and it's all fucking lights out
motherfucker. But the beauty of this is,
this is going to remind you something,
Joe, just keep watching watching. Oh Shit.
Isn't it dishonorable to grab some of
these chest hair and Rick and off them
though when you were in the Colosseum,
whatever happens happens in this family.
You're trying to, as long as you
don't lie, but watch all these,
watch all this is still slow mall. Nobody
knows nothing. Why? Hold on. Hold up.
How fake is this role of calcium?
They're finding and look,
I'll thinking that brick
wall was behind them.
They keep showing like a picture of
the Coliseum and then a brick wall.
This is crazy shit.
Chuck Norris and Bruce Lee,
they slow everything down.
This is hilarious.
The sound that it makes every time
they throw kicks this hilarious too.
Yeah,
it's 40 years ago. Look at the camera
work. The guys trying Matt. He's like,
kick the fucking camera.
He's trying.
He wanted us out poster of the
Roman Colosseum mine poster.
They probably shut this in.
Laurel Canyon. Laurel Canyon.
Yeah.
Chuck Norris is wash his feet. He
kicks him in the face. Oh Chuck.
Oh, hands down. Damn. Damn. What? Wow.
To Chuck. Just shook it off.
Beautiful Hair back then.
Okay.
Hi.
Oh,
the oblique kick.
Look at John Jones style son Bruce Lee
was the first oh front leg round cake to
the face. Chuck Norris
goes down, don't it?
Nobody's ever seen anything like this
before. Back then, this didn't exist.
Never saw a fight and moved to 11 and
Tonya head almost blew up. You left.
They're looking for some, you'll say
something to you, Oh fuck them up.
Including your dad. You didn't give
a fuck when you left these movies.
Joe Rogan,
you know whether or not Bruce Lee ever
competed. You know, I mean, that was like,
the big thing about him is that he never
fought like Chuck Norris was like world
middleweight kickboxing champion.
At one point in time.
Bruce Lee definitely did
a lot of spark for sure.
There's no way it give you this good.
The way his timing in his movement,
his understanding of what would and
wouldn't work like these in a lot of ways,
even though some of it is ridiculous,
some of his movements are more realistic
than shit you see in the movies today.
The way he checks with
that old bleak kick.
The weight counters when you're moving in,
it's very realistic.
Like these scenes like
the way he's fucking,
this dude up is a lot like the way someone
who's at a really high levels fucking
somebody up in the UFC.
It's really a kind of ironic,
like the way he's the shit that
he's doing. What he does. No Bow.
That's a move and a half. I told you
in the 70s everybody swept Joe Rogan.
Everybody. You had a watch that
front leg you will get the sweat.
Once you got into range and you can two
punches laid out that you will get swept
dog.
Everybody sweat.
The sweep has disappeared from our
society. He broke his thought. Oh,
he broke his leg.
There you go.
What the fuck you think it dealing
with farmers leg zoos arm is it?
That's how my hand when I was out
of the eight balls, that's how
he did. He broke his arm and his legs.
Legs fucked up. He fucked them up.
He's trying to listen. Watch. This is
a tremendous movie. This is tremendous.
Guys. Next time you see Chuck Norris
dump looking dumb with the wig.
Think about this. Think
about this move. Look dog.
He gets up even though if it's a
movie. Bruce was very smart. He goes,
let this fucking guy out.
It's a great scene though.
It can't stand,
but he gets up.
This was a good fucking scene. He
gets up. This is tremendous guys
at him. Look at him. He's trying
to throw kicks. Can't get up.
I forget how it ends. Does it? He
kill him. Just boil alert. Beautiful.
It's a beautiful ending. Even got up
correctly with the fucking damaged leg.
The cat.
Oh yeah. Mother fuckers. This
is cinematography one on one.
It you gotta make good team.
Oh my God.
He killed him.
The gets him first time ever.
He's upset that he had to kill him.
Dove might've been the first
guillotine ever in a movie, I believe.
Backing up a second,
I believe that was an arm in good team,
which is particularly difficult
to pull up. I don't think, uh,
I don't agree with his technique here.
Let me say back it up. Just so hair.
Is that a arm in?
Let's see here.
Can't see his other arm.
I feel like that's a arm and
gaiety in which I call bullshit.
No, it's not our men isn't it? Looks like
it is. It's hard to finish that one, man.
You've got to get up high on the neck
or you got to have an unbelievable
squeeze. Let's see. What do you get? Nope.
I don't know.
Tough to tell where his arm was.
It was if Chuck Norris had the under
Hook there. It's very hard to, well,
why don't turn it off. Watch
what he does. This is, this is,
this is tremendous guys,
which he was a fucking soldier
and he wrote all these, you know,
he wrote all of these
though. Look, watch, watch.
Oh, the music plays. Dusts off
his Kung Fu Dragon. By the way,
how many black guys dressed like that?
I turned 1970s and
eighties has a full outfit.
My mom was gonna send me back the Cuba.
They sent me to the Santa Maria praise
and didn't know what was wrong with me.
Here we go guys. No, no, no, no, no.
What happened there?
Just a youtube comment at the home and
he goes and gets his g and puts it on the
back of my car like is he back on top
of that his belt and makes it look nice
for him. Very nice group.
That's the guys. Come on.
Do you think that this is garbage?
This is not good. This is not good.
This is garbage, don't you?
How dare you? You know what?
Pull up the trailer to hard times.
Pull up the trailer.
Heart
team 73 watching trail was. Then we'll
go to the mechanic. Watch the trailer.
You got to see the trailers to the good,
the bad, the ugly, all those movies.
It was a different type of editing.
It was a different type of cut.
Very impressive.
Fuck man. It was a different world
back then, man. A different world,
a lot more believable back
then. Charles Bronson. James,
why does it say Charles prostanoids chair
pick up
the money's made on?
What does it feel like
to knock somebody down?
It makes me feel a hell of a
lot better than it does him.
1933 America had hit the skids.
People were out of work.
Wow, I'm out of luck. Third refill cost.
Life was as tough as a cheap steak
was hard at the time.
I got a husband in jail.
No job and no prospects.
A man had to live by his wits.
Know he was when they made this movie,
good would have gets long odds. What
kind of ads you talking to? Five to one
d deal by his fists.
Columbia.
There's an old dude, great shape.
That was dude that he fights.
It was a gas station attendant. I get
enough across from paramount. He got that.
He got that in the longest yard.
Really soft
and hit hard.
James Coburn as speed born con man,
50 50 and I'll scratch best and expenses.
Oh side bets.
I keep 75% who could make a fortune and
a day I propose a toast to the best man.
I know. Meat and flat broke.
I need some money fast.
You don't want no trouble.
Just you pay your debts.
Spi was the hustler broke
his car or the sledgehammer.
When you change about
that shame was the her.
You ever get scared when you do live
together?
They just couldn't be beat.
You give us their money.
Now that money take,
you want to see another Charles Bronson,
James Colver, Jill ironman and
Strother Martin. There are knockout
in hard times.
God Damn we punch has the
exact same sound effect.
Every punches.
It's such a weird artificial sound
like why didn't they like have someone
actually punt then and like
get the sound from that.
Then somebody wants make that sound
and then everyone just accepted that so
because why wouldn't you just sit there
and just go like that instead? Well,
you know they have those Foley artists,
those guys that make sound for movies
and they just decided on a sound.
It's like would clap and together
or something like that. No,
you want to see a real trailer.
Let me show you a real train trailer.
This is what took trailers
to the next level.
Scheft please see all Hunky Dory music
shaft took it to the next level of shaft.
Woke you up in the movie
theater with that Funky Guitar.
I remember this one would
be, yes, this, there was a,
they did a documentary on John Fitch
and it was a really good documentary.
Hold on, sorry. And but
one part of it was like,
it was all about the gritty
real life of a contender.
A guy like fighting GSP for the title.
But when they showed some
of the fight footage,
they had sound effects over
the punches. It was like, Shh,
shh. And I was like, Whoa,
Whoa, whoa, Whoa, whoa.
What are you doing?
Like you guys have like
the realest Shit on earth.
You're showing guys fighting in a cage
and you're having sound effects over over
punches. I don't know if they kept
it in. I didn't get it. See it again.
I only saw like it was,
I think it's called such great heights.
It's a documentary. They made a
way back. Um, what year was that?
I was right up to the
fight. The GSP. Yeah,
they shot the documentary
with him beating GSP.
They thought he was going to be cheap.
My page GSP. So that was, it was good.
I watched your documentary but I
mean I don't think they've shot it.
Thinking he was going to beat him.
Did they deserve,
they shot it hoping he
was going to beat him,
but knowing that this is a really
tough fight and, but I just was like,
why are they have sound effects?
I hope they pulled it out because other
than that it was a great documentary.
It's um,
it's just weird when you get,
like you start mixing things like you're,
you're adding sound effects.
Talking an actual fight. Like imagine
if like UFC started doing that.
Like every time somebody hits
somebody they added a sound effect.
Like you wouldn't know what, what's real,
what's not. The lines get super blurry.
They have a guy like in the truck that's
like got a button they press is every
time you fuck somebody he's had
three different sounds. Boom.
Pish posh.
It's possible one day
someone's going to do it.
So I'm going to doll
up some fake ass shit.
I don't like it when they do it with
stand up. Oh that's bad. Don't know it.
They do it with TV shows.
I don't like what they do with it.
Just something it lets me,
makes you out of it just makes me
not want to watch it no more. Yeah,
laugh tracks and sitcoms are
very confusing, very confusing.
They use these laptops,
laugh tracks on sitcoms sometimes when
the sitcoms aren't even shot in front of
an audience or they did at one point
in time that it wasn't just the,
they added last juice up a joke,
which they definitely do,
but it was also that
they did it like they,
they weren't even in front
of an audience at the time.
Then they added like some fake laughs
where they thought it should be funny,
which is so weird because you're watching
it at home and you're supposed to Lego,
you're supposed to like go along with it,
but it's so inorganic.
It's almost like a light goes off.
It tells you time to laugh now.
Time to laugh now and I
kind of has the same effect.
It's so weird watching Lucky Louie,
which was Louis C k his first show because
it was in front of a laugh track or a
studio,
I think it was a studio audience and it
was just so weird because he would like
get something out of the
fridge or be like, oh no, Hey
Jim Norton and to be there,
it's so awkward. Well, yeah, that
didn't work out that show. But uh,
he figured it out. You figured out
how to do it, just do it all yourself,
which is really crazy
that someone does that.
And he does the whole thing
himself. Pretty amazing. You know,
a lot of the writing produces it himself,
edits it.
He used to edit it on a little laptop. I
mean, I don't know how he's doing it now,
but back in the day he's talking about,
I use editing is showing
a 12 inch Mac book.
He's still always do
his own for his website.
He should always do his
own stuff like videos.
And he had like podcasts a long
time ago that he used to do himself.
It was like little youtube. Yeah, youtube
videos. And then the podcast, well,
he had a video podcast.
So if you,
if you go on iTunes right now and look
up Louis C K podcast is actually still up
there. It's really weird. How
many times did he do it? Not many.
Like six or seven times, but
I remember back in the day
before, uh, that Dane Cook,
Louis C K audio thing. I would always
try to help them out. Like, like, Hey,
would you like any help doing videos?
And he's like, I got it. I know how to,
I know how to edit video. And then I'm
like, oh damn. That's pretty sweet. Yeah,
he always edited and he was,
well he was a director too.
You can directed Pootie Tang back in
the DNA. That's right. Yeah, he's a,
he's done a bunch of different
things. Fine. He's a creative dude.
He's got all those guys weird. He's
weird, you know, take on things.
It's a very uniquely him.
And you see that on the show too,
that show Louie doesn't remind you of
any other show. It's weird, you know,
it's like
very uniquely him.
You know his idea of what's funny,
watch what the show is successful
because he does it from a to z.
Well this shame he has to do
everything for a year but you ADC.
But that's how it becomes good.
I think that's the only way to
make anything and not like you.
You're going to have a different idea
of how to do something then Brian is,
and Brian's going to have a different
idea than Sam Tripoli and it's just down
the road. It's the, no matter what,
it's real hard to get everybody to
agree on shit and it's real hard to,
one of the things that make someone look
really funny is their own unique like
sense of humor and when you add in a
bunch of other people's sense of humor,
sometimes that original,
whatever would be funny about the
original thing just doesn't come out.
It's not the same anymore because there's
so many different like things that
you've added to it.
It's kind of like changing water down.
It doesn't feel like Joey Diaz his words.
Like if I saw Sitcom,
somebody put a sitcom around you but you
had a bunch of other guys writing for
you, man, I, I'm pretty
sure I'd be able to tell.
I'm pretty sure I'd be able to tell
that it's not the guys riding from me.
It's what the network does
to it. That too. That's
why Louie controls the thing a to z
because we all know that you do the table
read on Tuesday,
you rehearsed fucking Wednesday,
you rehearse Thursday morning and Thursday
afternoon you do a run through and
the fucking network comes in and the
producers and then that night before you
leave they give you notes and then you
do it again the next day in front of
those fucking people again
you to give you a note.
Then you're shooting in front of a live
audience or whatever the fuck you do on
Friday night at six o'clock. So
it's, it's really weird. Like,
sometimes you might have a great
line and the audience laughs,
but they'll come back and say,
take that line out because a,
it offends somebody or our next
episode, you know, and you're like,
what the fuck you talking about it?
This is a great line.
I can't put them with this shit.
But that's uh,
what Louis success comes in that
he went to the network and said,
let's not do this and I'll take
this money. But this is my end.
I'm handling this remade the z the
first time since 25 year old we know,
comes in with a suit,
just graduated from Syracuse
to tell me how to do my comedy.
The deal is over because
that's what ruins all of them.
That's the tough part of the comic.
And you, when you're, uh, doing a,
a TV show,
it,
you're on the weekends out there talking
about getting stabbed and eating some
of these asshole and now you're doing
a Disney show from Tuesday to fucking
Friday telling me you can't say
how you got to say something else.
And the show sucks.
One of the great successes that you have
to take it off for Roseanne Barr was
that when Roseanne Barr went for it,
she went for it.
When they told her that they wanted
her to not Cosby out of the box,
she went for it.
But you know what she did?
She went back to the comedy store and
she hide all those guys that she thought
the Quirky. Even if she could get
one line per show out of them,
they would work the $5,000 and guess what?
Sometimes you know those riders,
they give you a networks now 10 times.
They don't learn how to write a fucking
Columbia or I'm gonna fucking Philly or
University of Houston, wherever they
went to fucking do you know what?
We were heading on a drop of a dime,
bro.
I like when you get a couple of comics
with a couple people that know how to
write and put that together,
but I don't want four guys.
They just specifically writers for a
comic like myself, don't work for comic,
like uh, the bacon guy or somebody
who's clean or something like that.
But for guys like Jim Jeffrey,
you're not going to get network fucking
writers to write with his fucking
craziness and his mind.
You got to get two guys with a similar
thing and mix them with two guys that
know formats and maybe and yeah,
that's how I don't think,
I think he's got to write his own
stuff. Oh yeah, yeah. And then,
and then you come in
there. No, no, listen.
And they'd give you a line and how many
times have they given you a fucking line
and why you're looking at
it after you rehearse it.
I go with what my gut tells me.
Well,
if you say aligned to me and
rehearsal and I spit it back at you,
I say the first thing I say
is what my gut tells me.
Then they'll come over and send
the bitch with the glasses and say,
the line is that you're going to kill
the cat yellow, right. Watch this, Bam.
And it works again.
What's the line here?
The line is the one I just said to
kill a cat and getting no fucking funny
response. But the network will want you
to say killed the cat. I'm just saying.
Right, because of the writers will tell
you the writers to tell you I've, yeah,
I've seen that many, many. So
if the comic says fuck you,
I'm going to do this line. You mix that
with the two guys you got and that,
because the comedians are coming
from a different school of thought,
the guys that are writers,
they don't have a structure.
I'm talking about structure and what's
going work and you're gonna get four
comedians together.
Yes.
So we'll have an explosion and we'll
have helicopters and the chick flies out
that cost $1 million. Oh,
they didn't know that.
Now they've got to
rewrite it all over again.
You get two guys that know what the fuck
they're right and the structure Shit,
you get too crazy fucking comedians to
write for you and then you add to the
fucking mix. But guess what?
Your Rogan, that's a lot of work.
And even then it's hard to do. That's
a lot of work. It's hard to do.
It's hard to pull off.
You're not going to write.
It's not that many of you that you're
not going to write and do everything.
What you gotta do is get,
listen,
10 years ago I would watch Chris
Rock and I always admired that.
And then I found out the
real story when Chris Rock,
Chris rock would use his specials.
He would hire neck Louie and
Richard and Richard, Jenny,
he had that much faith on.
They all came up together.
And if you watch two of
his specials in those days,
you see all three of them in this special,
you could see what his son,
Nick Dipaolo joke in there.
You know, and I'm not saying,
I'm going to tell the joke
that Joe Rogan gave me.
I'm going to add my flavor to it.
You know, you're never going to,
you're never going to have somebody
come up there and go, Joe, dude,
this line on stage state,
you never that type of guy,
but somebody might give you a
good idea premises probably.
It'll give you some good prompts.
And if you watch, uh, you know,
even just the fat hanging over the heel,
that's a nick depalo type of thing.
And then when he says that
joke, you know, you saw it,
you saw the development of the special,
you saw that maybe it's an hour special.
He put 30 minutes in,
nick put 10, Richard,
Jenny put three and Louie put 20.
He had enough trust in those guys.
That's when the specialist good.
When you have guys who really know you
guys that could go to, you know what?
You might have somebody like that, right?
Something and they go, you know what?
I wrote something. It's a little too wild
for me, Joey. Maybe it'll work for you.
And you hear it out and you're like,
maybe it was,
I'm not going to use it
because somebody else wrote it.
But you understand me sometimes once you
have that type of trust and that level
and you could see, you could see
it in Christmas specials. It's,
it's a comedy collaboration and it works.
But somebody in there has to be
structured. I'm funny. Joe Rogan,
I don't know how to say shut off the kick,
but I'm not structured.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm not structured well,
that's because the beauty of what
you do is not as structured thing.
You know when you're, when you're on
stage, it's just wild loose thing.
That's part of the fun of it.
That's the vibe.
That's part of the fun
of like how you perform.
So like when you try to
turn that into a sitcom,
it's like you're capturing
lightening in a bottle.
Lightning only exists for a brief
moment of time flashing through the sky.
You know, they got, they were about to
make uncle buck again. It was a black guy,
black guy, Mike Abbott, who I liked,
who I is doing a lot of shit he's doing
prior to, he's doing prior to the
prom with uncle buck is anybody they,
uncle buck, when they write it,
they write it as a crazy guy.
That guy has to be naturally crazy to
sell this. You know, anytime they'll,
they'll sell it now though.
Saw the guy who smokes a cigarette
and goes to the gym. Oh, he's edgy,
you know,
goes to,
he's playing like volleyball with
a beer in his hand or you know,
something stupid where that's what
they're selling instead of the attitude.
That's what, that's what you
want to see is the attitude.
It's not what the riders,
you know,
his words just don't want to
see another uncle buck. Yeah.
I don't want to see a guy who takes
the kids to the track that's been done.
That's been done. Leave it alone, you
know. But that's where it's at. But again,
the remake, all that shit, but they
don't put on wide world of sports,
which is a real education. You
understand me? And now we got,
we got real sports on HBO who
they tackle those subjects.
They go to India and watch the young
kids with the Campbells and the whole
fucking deal. So, and yeah, it was last
time it was talking about the, the,
the people in Nepal, the Sherpas, the US
people up to the top of Mount Everest.
Holy Shit. They make like
$5,000 a year. Like 24 of them,
25 of them have died over the
last couple of years. Scary.
Scary Shit is only a hundred of them and
these people are carrying all this shit
up to the top of Mount
Everest, day in, day out.
You know they spend long fucking hours
sleeping on the side of a glacier.
It's scary shit.
Wild Shell man.
He did a really good job of
capturing all wide world sports.
I mean I'm real sports with Bryant Gumbel.
Well you St Brian,
have you seen the new
Nirvana? A documentary that
was just announced? It's a,
it's actually court. Courtney has
lent all her personal movies for one.
So like her home movies and stuff and
there's also a 13 minute song that Kurt
never released and stuff and it's,
it's heartbreaking if you watch it.
It's really well done and it's
coming out next month or so.
But it's a check it out.
There's a lot it,
they mix the animation and a lot of
different medias with it and it's pretty
depressing movie.
It's hard to believe that guy killed
himself even after it happened and killed
them, killed them. She tried that killed
him. She poisoned them. I don't know.
She put the gun. Those are this
whole conspiracy theory up there.
Do you believe you gotta Sneeze? I
don't blog. I used to believe it,
but the more I watch
and learn about current,
it seems like he was just a tortured
soul and yeah, it seems like he was,
I mean heroin especially like severe
heroin addictions. Very depressing.
Very depressing.
You know what's beautiful though?
What the sky,
how America gets always whenever they
find the recordings and the safe.
I gotta take a leak or who recorded it
sounds last 13 minutes from him. Listen,
if it's any good, he would have
fucking released it. All right. Yeah.
America loves buying shit that
somebody founded a fucking safe.
It's fucking amazing. Oh, America
loves it. Oh these are the rereleased,
the unreleased Tupac, the Ga. That shit.
That album was fucking terrible. Yeah.
He's two pocket. If he wanted it release,
he would have fucking released it.
All right.
The reason why it's
unreleased cause he listened to
it and said this fucking blows.
I think this movie definitely he is
going to make a huge new surge of Nirvana
fans that it may be,
haven't really fallen into that whole yet.
You know,
there's a lot of young kids.
I didn't even know what Nirvana is
still me doing not doing nothing.
Fuck is wrong with you. Well how does
that you, you uh, you, the podcasts,
you do a church of what's happening now.
You guys now have ahd HD cameras and
you're doing it. I do. You do it.
How many times a week do
you do it now? Twice. Twice.
And have you switched it
from the six in the morning?
Shit that used to do now it's
normal times. Yeah. What time is it?
Certain days
different tomorrow. Two o'clock with
Steven about where every day is different.
We used to do it Mondays on Wednesdays,
but I had some shit going on today.
I could only do this with Joe.
So you have to be flexible.
I'm home the next four weeks so I can do
it whatever fucking bad one thing. Yeah.
Great. I usually always do one Monday.
Monday, you got to have one of the week,
Wednesday or Thursday,
he'd do what the fuck you want.
Did you see ra or boy,
Ari Shaffir this Friday he not only had,
is a special that they have
is also followed by his new
TV show. Uh, uh, you know,
at the storytelling show. Come
on. Yeah, it's great. Come on.
And this was like the couple of days
after that Howard stern was just like,
who is this Ra guy?
Meanwhile,
he has like two shows on a Friday night
at midnight on comedy central and it's
billboards everywhere of him in the
fucking middle of it. All right.
Well he's got one billboard on sunset,
but it's beautiful having it right
in front of his house. You know,
Howard does that. He pretends he doesn't
know what you're doing, you know,
and PR pretends he doesn't know like
that the kid is a successful comic.
You just, he mocks people,
you know, it was, I mean,
someone's talking shit about him.
He's going to mock them.
It not going to bother Google
searching him. Why would he do that?
Whatever he says like in his, in
his reach, you know, it's Gospel.
So Ari becomes a loser. It's
the whole thing. Kind of funny.
I can't believe that he talked
about him for 25 minutes. I'm just,
I understand that.
And he backtracked so many times.
Did he listened to it?
Cause he said that he never,
I mean he literally said podcasts are
for losers and he kind of backtrack that
whole saying and he's just not paying
attention to what everyone else is talking
about. He's just kind of like, no, no,
no, no, no. If you want to be in radio,
and we're like, we're not trying
to be in radio. He's just,
you think he's just protecting
his value before Sirius radio?
I think he's talking shit.
And when he talks shit, people
start talking about him.
I think he's just, he's a smart
guy. He knows what he's doing.
He's like by by saying things
that he like saying that our,
he's like doing a standup into a podcast,
you know,
just I guess he's buying well if you
want to be by yourself and no one's
listening, you know, get a
job and terrestrial radio,
those jobs don't even exist anymore.
I mean try and try and get,
and not only that,
that's not what a podcast is,
what a comic is doing in a podcast and
just having a good time just sitting
around and talking shit.
You're not trying to like,
like the idea of like the pressure of
being hired like somehow or another.
That's good. This is what's good.
What's good is the creative process.
Like what comes out of a podcast when
you're putting it together and the
conversations flowing,
you're trying to figure out what story
to tell and how to say it and it comes
out and people who are listening, the
entertainment value, that's undeniable.
That's what,
that's what's important.
If you want to just talk about how much
money's being made and where it's like
you're missing the entire point,
like the missing the entire point.
If that's what you're talking about with
stand up. If you were saying, you know,
will your stand up, you stand
up, you're not making any money,
you don't even know what you're doing.
You know I've sold out arenas,
but your standup is not.
Imagine a comic saying that to another
comic who was trying to figure out how to
do it. What's, what's,
what's good about standup and what's good
about podcasts is that people enjoy it.
That's it. That's what's good about
everything. Everything you make,
whether it's a movie or a song, do
people enjoy it? If they enjoy it,
then you're successful,
then it's successful.
The idea that you can't make any
money on it, it's just not true.
So if he says that,
I feel like he's trolling,
I feel like he's trying to
get people to talk about them.
If that's what he always did,
man,
you've got to understand
how clever that dude was.
He would go into markets and you can't,
you don't just compete with
a guy in a market. Okay?
You go into market and you own him.
You go into market,
you put up fucking posters.
You said you stage a fake funeral for mark
and Brian, you see, give him a funeral,
man. You, you, you mock
people to the end of time.
You spend hours talking shit
about them on the radio.
It's some gangster shit and that's what
he always did. It's straight gangster.
He would go in and just jack at town.
But you've got to understand
what you're dealing with.
Like this guy's not stupid man.
If he's talking shit,
he wants people to talk shit back.
He knows it does a shitload of podcasts.
And when you start talking shit back then,
you know,
you're comparing your accomplishments
with his accomplishments in his head.
And in his mind he can't lose.
But he, I think he trolls.
I used to just too smart.
It's not just that he doesn't believe
that like keeps saying to get a job in
terrestrial radio. He doesn't even
have a job in terrestrial radio.
You know what I mean?
He's on serious and you can't just
jump right into serious obviously.
But for comics, like that's
not a smart move. You want
to be nationwide, a podcast.
Like he's got to know that guys use
podcasts to sell tickets and people that
most people have never heard of,
you know,
outside of the standup
comedy and podcasts world,
like Thompson Gora is
not a household name,
but that mother fucker is selling
out places all over the country.
Small theaters. He,
yeah, everywhere he goes,
he's selling out clubs and it's directly
because of his podcast to say that
that's not a good idea and that he
should be on the radio in Connecticut
somewhere is that's not
true. So he, I don't believe,
I don't think he believes that.
I think he's just talking shit.
I think Ari Shaffir ears
podcasts probably has led him to,
a lot of it is a success and comedy
central and in his TV show and the
storytelling show and like there's a path,
you know from Ari starting
that podcast too, you know,
and keeping up with standup comedy that,
that he can't deny has helped his career
100%. Everybody that does a podcast
has benefited from their podcast.
If they do stand up every single bump
person, w w this guy named h diesel,
he does a podcast out of Austin.
He's the one that first turned me onto
this whole Howard Stern podcast thing. Uh,
he, uh, made a great point
is if you look online,
if you go to youtube and you
find some low recent channel,
our recent shows of Howard stern on there
and then you look at recent shows have
you, it's amazing the
difference of the numbers.
It's like there was one that he brought
up that was like hundreds of thousands
of somebody just, you
know, you know, put up a,
an episode or you put up an episode
on Youtube, uh, hundreds of thousand.
Then there was like one in the same
time period of Howard Stern, 2000,
but this is like the main guy that puts
up Howard stern show every day on the
youtube. So it's just interesting. What
is his numbers? Cause none of us know,
serious probably doesn't even know,
you know.
Well they know, they know he's huge. Don't
get it twisted. Howard Stern's gigantic.
I don't, I'm not saying it's not gigantic,
but what is his numbers? Well, who cares?
That's your, you're doing this. You're
playing the same game as he's playing now.
You can't win. He's, he's Howard Stern.
Like you gotta like what does his numbers?
Jesus Christ,
it's probably like 20 million people.
Who the fuck knows what it is?
I don't know how many people have
Sirius satellite radio. Well,
I guarantee you if people have Sirius
satellite radio and they're listening to
the morning, Howard Stern's, the number
one thing they listen to a guarantee you,
I guarantee you.
I know.
It's why a lot of people I know
bought series in the first place.
100% it's not a small number.
I mean the reason why this already
thing got so huge, it really,
like a lot of people might
not listen on Youtube,
but a lot of people are
definitely listening on satellite.
100% like on Xm and Sirius,
whatever it is,
that 100% there's a lot of
people listening to that.
It's not a flop by any imagination.
So if just because things
don't get traction on Youtube,
you know people listen
to that show in your car.
That's what the stern show is always been.
You listen in your car,
you listen on the way to work.
When you're commuting you listen home
and now because series has two channels,
they have Howard 100 and
Howard 101 you get his show,
they get replaced throughout the day and
then on 101 you get all these old shows
that he did.
Like you'll hear him interview in Bon Jovi
and the fucking nineties or something.
I mean if you have an iPhone,
you have every single TV show and
it's free because you have youtube
[inaudible], Sam, Sirius,
satellite radio and your price.
That's what we're talking about it.
Yeah.
I'm just saying that how pointless
it is kind of for that kind of thing.
Now that we all have youtube
or cell phones and that
have Bluetooth because like
we can get Howard stern show right now
that he did today on her phone. Right.
But you can't listen to it live.
Like,
like this morning I was listening to a
s a serious the opn Jimmy show and uh,
they had some guy on from boardwalk
empire. I'm listening to it live.
I mean he's talking live,
you're hearing it live.
Like when that there's something about
that that's always going to be appealing.
People love to,
to hear a show that's going on live and
you love the fact you just get in your
car and you press XM and you find out
what the fuck is on it or serious,
you know,
you press and you find out what's on.
Like you don't have to go search into
your podcasts, you can just hit your,
your favorites. You've got one on one
and you're tuning into the channel.
There's always going to be a benefit in
that. But they're probably go all good.
A wind up doing both.
That's what it's probably going to be.
It's probably gonna be like some sort of
a serious show but also having to be a
podcast too.
And this the the networks like the idea
that you're going to be able to keep
like a lockdown on TVs,
car radios with satellite,
like that's not happening anymore.
They're starting to,
everybody knows that he doesn't like
the idea that Howard stern doesn't know
that is ridiculous.
He knows about stitcher and cars and
need to do is very savvy so he knows that
they're going to have,
without a doubt they're going to have
Internet access in 90% of the cars and
just a few years.
Everybody that has a new car,
like you get a Cadillac now
they have this Escalade.
I rented one when I was in Utah. It's
fucking incredible. First of all,
they're amazing. They're so smooth that
it's not a, it's not a gauge anymore,
not a gauge cluster. It's an LCD
screen with an artificial gaze.
Costs are huge fucking map, like
the navigation systems, giant,
super comfortable ride.
Magnetic suspension.
It's got a built in internet connection.
It's a fucking driving
Internet connection. So you
have like builtin Internet.
Like you use it as like a wifi
hub and you can have your laptop,
you could download iTunes,
you could fucking stream different
things on the screens. It's crazy.
That's this is you're going to have
podcasts, apps for all those things,
and you're going to be able
to say, where's the Church
of what's happening now?
And you're going to pee. You gotta be
able to press a button, you're stealing,
we'll, uh, go to church of
what's happening now. You
know, and then like, you know,
would you like to play an episode?
Yes. Episode four with, uh, you know,
fill in the blank. You know, whoever
the fuck it is, big John McCarthy, Bam.
And then that shit starts playing.
Welcome to the Church of what's happening.
And at least science starts talking and
then you drive it down the road. That's,
that's in demand. And that's inevitable.
It's, but right now we're not there yet.
And I think guys like Howard stern are
very, very clever. He's smart as shit.
You know, the idea that he doesn't
know that all this stuff is going on.
That's preposterous.
He's trolling,
he trolled Ari and he got already talked
shit about him and he talks shit about
all right. And now it's his crazy
thing and that's what he does.
That's what I think.
I also think he, you're right,
cause he's such a computer nerd and,
but I also think that maybe with like
all these TV shows and flying from La to,
you know, or whatever he does or whatever
your schedule is, maybe he doesn't,
maybe he's completely a different person.
He comes home,
it takes a little nappy
poo and wakes up and
I doubt it. You know what also think
he's also in negotiations with serious,
like there's some sort of contract things.
So what is it going to do?
He belittles the competition, he mocks
them and then it becomes gospel, you know,
to a lot of people,
what he says is Gospel.
We started talking about podcasts being
for losers, you know, and then you know,
people comparing the podcast to his
show. You know, he's got a point,
he's got a point,
he's got like how many millions of
fucking cars have serious built into them.
You know, my, my car has it built in.
When I bought it, it's in, it was on,
I started watch right away. I don't even
have to order any special package I get.
Oh,
how it used to have to pay for like
Howard one o one Howard 100 like a special
package to get opie and Anthony. It was
a special package. Not Anymore. Nope.
It's all the same price. I'll just
give me your car as soon as you get it.
It's on there. I think everyone has it.
I think everyone has it in their cars,
but like,
like I haven't been to cars and they
both expired and I think a lot of people
like myself called and go like, how,
how much is it? And they're like, oh,
it's 150 for a year. And
you're like, no. Why,
what $150 to take about how much
booze you buy in a week. That's like
a Florentine classic final studio,
54 classic vinyl.
I get Ivana, Soundgarden hair of
the dog. I get all of that. That's,
that's uh, whatever, uh, this
like 10 fucking things on that.
How would one 100 I don't
live without Sirius radio.
Mccall. I like it. I like it.
I like to hold on. No, I have
a, I have the phone. Brian,
you've got to use your phone to get that.
I have a,
how many people have Spotify in their
car but very tiny number if any, right?
I mean think,
I think everybody either has Bluetooth
or the plug into their phone where they,
where they, they do because every
single person I know does, oh yeah,
but think about your crowd. Your, you're
hanging out with a bunch of young comics.
You know, a lot of people don't use
Bluetooth yet with their stereo.
They just don't, they don't use
your phone to, and if you do use it,
you got to fuck with your phone while
you're driving and go look through things
and try to search for something with Xm.
You just pressed a button.
It's right there.
You're driving serious where I'm driving.
I'm saying like the things you were
saying, like the seventies radio station,
the eighties radio station, they have this
on Pandora, they have this on Spotify.
It's free, open several steps and
you're not, you're not listening.
Several stuck in costs,
so you just leave it there.
You pay the Vig and you move on with
your fucking life and express the bucket,
but it's programming. It's putting
rotations. I got 10 stations in the,
all of them are throwing fucking eat
at every minute of the day. Yeah,
your preset, I don't mean you have to
Spotify. I don't even know all this shit.
I got it all in.
Then it comes up the fucking car that
took demand saying it's undeniable that
it's a good value. If you're someone who
sits in traffic and it's entertainment,
you need entertainment. It's undeniable.
There's hundreds of radio stations.
There's a bunch of different talks.
They should just BBC stations.
You tuned into an, anytime they're
talking about diamond mining in Africa,
you flip to the next one.
They're interviewing.
Someone in Bangladesh says dealing with
some isis attack. It's fucking great.
Again, the wise call. Good. Just because
there's Spotify and just because there's,
there's a lot of extra steps
involved in all those things.
If you're going to want to like set up,
you're going to do Pandora.
You're not going to listen to the BBC.
You're not going to
listen to Howard Stern.
He not going to listen to opiod and Jimmy,
if you want to hear those things
and those things are good,
you got to do it with serious. The idea
that 150 bucks a year was a lot of money.
Come on, man, that's 10 bucks a
month. 10 bucks a month. Ain't shit.
10 bucks a month for every
single day you get something.
It seems to me like it's a value.
It's just not, it's not that bad
a thing.
It's the everything.
Everybody has this idea that because it
has to be one or the other, you know,
they,
they can all coexist.
It's nothing wrong with having
a satellite radio in your car.
I get my wife's car and she
listens to all that shit.
The gentiles was listened to the gets
good rush ball and all that. Fuck Shit.
You know my life. This is why
there's, they fucking come.
I get in the car and I got to give
her a look. What is this shit?
She got three stations program to cause.
Tell white people shit.
Their world's gonna savage.
Yeah. Obama's in Japan.
Mrs. Oh I got in the car this
morning when he alive in Japan.
Mrs. Obama at the fuck.
I used to listen to a couple
of those guys on serious too.
There's a few of those guys you can get.
Those guys are awesome.
They just get an air dry.
I can't,
the only guy I like is the guy that
comes on lunch touch Steve Harvey.
That was my dog for you.
I learned about Steve Harvey in the
mountains of Colorado lunchtime.
Everything ends in Colorado.
Steve Harvey,
the Alps are empty so
you're going to do so,
but do you listen to a the Steve Harvey
Radio shows? Is that what it is? Whatever.
Whenever Tara, I don't listen to it
no more. I went like two years now.
I'm stuck on lithium and classic
fucking vile the way up here.
They had Elton John from funeral,
from a friend that I'm,
you don't listen tonight. Show was
just telling John Anymore. Hold on.
This is what he was with Bernie Taupin.
We don't like Elton John.
I just want to tell him John is a,
he's got this, a dolce and Gabbana boy,
a band called dolce and
Gabbana. He's on a roll. Yeah,
because they said something about gay
people adopting kids or having kids.
I forget what the fuck and he's gotten.
Listen, let me tell you some dough.
Cenk a banner done regimen. Elton John
Speaks. People listen. Fuck. D F Hutton.
That's the gay community. That
deep, deep pocket gay community.
Not these little guys jumping up and
down at that place in Santa Monica.
This is the deep beep money gays.
They don't give a fuck.
Why would anybody do that?
Because shit
fuck ain't people have is this.
You don't fuck with Elton John.
You don't fuck with Barbara Streisand.
There's a couple people.
You just leave the fuck alone. Let's
find out what it is. Don't change a band.
A band.
What's up B
music from Spotify. Ringwood. What else?
My point was just fucking go on with the
phone and crash more options for me to
take this fucking car off a cliff.
That's what you're giving me. No,
I'm just saying that the future I think
of that is suspect because I think
phones or cars are now having Spotify
automatically in there and Pandora just
like a satellite radio.
And I just think the future of that is,
is you know, and them now, I don't
know, it just doesn't seem very good.
The future of what Sirius
satellite radio program,
the idea that it's everything
is programmed for you.
The difference between that and something
like Spotify or Pandora is you're
going to go searching for stuff. They
had the same thing. What do you mean?
They have the same fight?
If fight has radio stations and
so does Pandora has radio station.
So if you want a seventies radio station,
they have that and it's just random
seventies you know, it's been programmed.
So it will be star based then.
Then the people that'll be subscribing
and of the people that specifically
want to see or listen to Howard
stern or listen to opium Chimi.
So in that case it makes him even more
important because this is a fucking giant,
multibillion dollar company. This is not
a small endeavor. If Howard stern left,
you want to talk about like the power
of podcast. Here's the power of podcast.
If Howard Stern said fuck you to Sirius
satellite radio at the end and started
his own podcast, do you have any fucking
people would jump ship and leave?
It would be enormous.
It would crash the company.
He probably wouldn't do it because he
owned stock. I mean I think he does.
At least that's what I've read.
Wasn't that part of the thing
that he owned stock in the
company if he wanted to?
Yeah. If he bailed and started his
own like podcast show and stead,
boy they,
I guarantee you they're fucking numbers
would drop off substantially because as
time goes on,
one thing you do have a point when I told
you about that escalate that I rented,
it has internet built into it.
It's not only like a step or two away
from something awesome being developed for
Cadillacs and the idea also if
you have full time all the time,
Internet connection like that and a car,
all you have to do is like set up apps
like an apple system or you have just
like you have on your phone. I mean that
could easily be the future of a car.
It could be just like a phone man.
It's to be nuts because you'll be able
to download apps into your fucking car,
but then people are going to hack your
car. That's going to be an issue too.
People gonna you're going to have a 24
hour internet connection in your cars.
People are gonna start
hacking people's cars.
They're going to disabled people's breaks.
Some guy's gonna fucking kill his
wife by disabling or breaks. Right.
They confuse things too.
That shit.
One day you fucking dragging
your windows open up.
It's 20 below and you can't close
them because that's what I don't like.
It's like when you were a kid and you
bought your first stereo and you went to
that dude on the corner, you go
to that $200, which stereo when I,
but you want it to Fisher because it
had the eight track tape cassette,
the record play, and the four speakers.
And he professional would say,
don't do that by components
because of the eight track works.
Then the whole thing is
damaged. Do you remember when
that, uh, that controversial?
Oh, you fucking think you deal with, fuck.
So fucking novice used to buy components.
So I didn't like the radio
when I was growing up. I
never bought a fucking radio.
I bought an amplify.
I could like I connect to the cassette
to it and I had a record player with, uh,
two of those fucking killer speakers.
I always seem to get off the trucks,
whatever the Bose,
this is way before bows.
This is fucking alone or south is there.
And uh, there was a guy who died
report or what the fuck is his name?
He died on sunset. He
crashed his car. And, uh,
that's one of the things
that they were saying.
They were saying that they think
that this guy's car had been hacked.
The fuck is his name.
Mine has that shit that freaks me out.
Like it's connected to the Internet.
Michael Hastings. Yes. Michael Hastings.
Thank you. This guy was like super
critical of, um, of the military.
Super critical of some,
some generals in particular
and the guy died his car,
like he fucking hit the gas and never let
up and drove right into a tree and his
car exploded. Electrocute him
right from the Balkans. Right.
That's when they send the fucking signal
right from norad and they fuck your
shit right up. Yeah.
Allegations of foul play,
getting to government,
you know, in the loop.
Everything was we're against
would just give them to them.
So I don't you want the Gulf that we
know the fucking cars with where we're at
in the cars.
They already know what our phones,
didn't they say two when he died
they found Methodist system.
I'm pretty sure that's what happened.
I always find the Methodist system that's
the way to fucking have this gown on
him. And he said that he was in
a very agitated state in quotes,
the sounds like a hit piece,
saying he was incredibly tense and worried
that his materials being surveilled
by the government.
Friends believe that Michael's line
of work led to a paranoid state.
USA Today reported that in
the days before his death,
Hastings believes his car was being
tampered with and that he was scared and
wanted to leave town. You know, it's,
it's one thing to kill yourself,
but a one thing to hit the gas full
clip and drive straight into a tree.
How many guys have done that?
I think if you're on Meth,
that would probably be where like, I'm
doing it. I'm going to die. I'm gonna die.
Maybe. Maybe. Maybe. That's exactly right.
Think about it. When you are in math,
you do make some shitty choices,
especially if you're about
to kill yourself on meth.
I just feel like most people would want
it to be like 100% like hitting a tree
with a car might just fuck you up.
I don't know how,
how hard you gotta be going
to hit a tree and live.
So they're saying it's fucking
foul play, correct? No,
they're saying they don't
think it's about PLO.
People think he was bananas and
he drove into a fucking tree.
I think it's even his own family.
He said that,
but they might just be
protecting themselves.
They might just be saying that publicly
because they don't, they're scared.
I mean this guy was fucking with generals.
Generals are professional killers.
I mean that's what they are. That's
what they do. They kill people overseas.
They killed people that are problems and
in a guy who's trying to take down the
general,
the general has done really good work
for the United States as far as like
military work and you know,
been a part of some important missions
and he's got a lot of clout and they
think that this guy is
trying to take them down.
Well that guy might as
well just be the enemy.
You're trying to remove one of the most
important components of the military.
You're trying to remove a general,
a general that's like been
very successful at war.
You could easily see why some people
would step in and say, you know what,
we're going to take this fucking
reporter out for the country,
and then that's how they would believe
that they were doing the right thing.
That could have happened,
man. I don't know.
I just don't think that it's a matter of,
I don't think it's a
matter of impossibility.
It's not impossible to control a car. In
fact, there's been some CIA guys to say,
you can do it. It can be done like
Google that Jamie, pull up. Ken,
you like Michael Hastings death.
Can you remote control a car?
Michael Hastings death.
See if there's a,
like there's a consensus on that
because I think you could do it.
It's a computer.
It's a fucking key.
I don't think there's anything that
shows that you could steer the car unless
it's one of those cars that has automatic
steering like Michael Hastings per
Sadie's. He had a
Mercedes, the new Mercedes,
you could drive those motherfuckers
around town like 30 miles an hour.
They will drive themselves. Okay.
You said it, they have like a,
a laser that detects cars in front of you.
They slow down.
There's cameras that detect where
the lanes are. They turned for you.
My, my uh, bug my Volkswagen.
I can unlock my cars through an APP or
my car doors through an app loaded this
what has been revealed as a result of
some research at universities that it's
relatively easy to hack your way into
the control system of a car and do such
things as cause acceleration when the
driver doesn't want acceleration or to
throw on the brakes when the driver
doesn't want the brakes on to launch an
airbag.
Wow.
You can do some really highly destructive
things now through hacking a car and
it's not that hard. Wow. Wow.
So if there was a cyber attack on a car,
and I'm not saying there was Clark added,
I think whoever did it would probably
get away with it. Oh, good Lord.
My sink, my Ford Sync, uh,
since reports to some office once a
month and it tells you my break breaks,
like how good my brake pads are.
Like everything about my car so it
knows everything about my car and has
connections to every part of my car.
It's got new machines and was fucking
with signal most of the whole front and
there was 60 days they send me reports to.
Would that makes sense though?
Your sleep apnea? I'm seeing he's not
driving around town into a fucking tree.
Fucking controlling his breathing refill.
You could go on a report
if the end of the month,
I don't know about the car thing.
Well,
they're going to have computers that can
control like the convergently control
anything,
right?
One of our sponsors is smart apps or
smart things and smart things. A is an a,
you can,
you can control your alarm system,
your electricity shut off your
lights off and on. I mean these, the,
these things are like,
if you could do it,
that means somebody else can't do it.
So don't open the fucking APP.
Mind your fucking business is fucking
business because that means somebody else
could too. So one night you're
at home getting your Dick Sucked.
Some 13 year old doesn't want to swat
you. He wants to fucking tango. Light.
Sound like fucking pump the guys thing.
Your House, you know you need that shit.
Don't fuck with it. Don't
open a door. If you know,
if you answered the email back that says
you have a relative that left your 5
million, guess what you're done. You
can put just delete that motherfucker.
He don't even open it.
Why don't you go back to a flip phone for
what it was cause he avoid all of this.
You and Ari. I don't know. He's
already gone to flip phone.
I'm going to make a confession today
because a lot of people are, no,
I don't even know what the
fucking happens. I don't
have it on my fucking phone.
You know the single APP on your phone?
I don't know nothing to
check. Twitter and hotmail. That's all
I wanted to chose their apps. That's it.
That's it.
Those are the two absent everything else.
Got another blood pressure thing.
Oh you have an from my heart stress
before the put my fingerprints on there.
It is hard stress because
one of my buddies,
John Cutler up in San Francisco,
send me it.
Then you connect to your iPhone
and check your blood pressure.
I take with me on the road to the gym
when I do sit ups before my head blows up.
That's an APP. Yep. Yeah, but I
don't know nothing about iTunes.
Like I give it to my wife and go here,
put this on there. I don't know nothing.
I don't know people who fucking, I got
myself a easy man. I got my fitness pal.
Dot. Come on here to count my
protein, carbs and all that shit.
But I don't do some incredible
shit with these things.
I don't do it from my phone.
I do it from the house,
but there's no misunderstandings.
None of the time I don't have my
glasses out of the fucking phone.
If you email me for something, they don't
get back to your text. Me, you fucked.
I don't have my glasses. Forget it.
The ice side is completely gone now.
I'm almost done here.
I'm almost fucking done here.
I got to go back to the doctor like in
two weeks. How bad is your eyesight? Uh,
the fucking left. I listen if you see
me in my car, just go on the left side.
A chance on the right cause I'm like,
you're fucking with that thing
and far. Is that everything or is it
the questions? I don't see nothing.
That's what the fucking closer, I don't
even see tweets no more. Really? Yeah.
I can't see tweets on my phone unless
there's a lot of light, you know? No,
those days are done John Real. It's
over. Yeah. My side is really though.
I could see a coke rock under a
fucking carpet looking at me now.
Look at me fucking now.
Nothing. Nothing guys.
It's a real fucking shame,
but that's what happens.
This is supposed to be some
exercises you can do for your eyes.
Steve Maxwell was telling
me about the other day.
It's like it's a book called
throw away your glasses and see,
and I had this woman on him,
Katy Bowman and she's one of the
things that she was saying is that you,
when you, your eyes, like
when you're looking at things,
everything in the same distance,
like you'll constantly looking at a
screen and it's like having a cast on like
it, it makes your, your eyes
atrophy. It's not good for it.
Like you're supposed to be looking
at things all different distances,
looking at things for far away,
looking at things from close up and,
and you look at things
all different distances,
your eyes stay pretty good but when
you're just constantly staring at a screen
on a regular basis, your eyes
start to get this shit. Definitely.
Definitely with me.
I could tell when I started really sitting
in front of a computer, my eyesight,
it just demolished it.
The 44 88 eight it up like fuck.
Some people are just constantly looking
at their phone. That does it too.
But if you can just incorporate a lot
of distance looking into your life,
like go outside and look at
things far away like your eyes.
We'll have like a better medium,
like let them focus on shit that's really
far away and focus on some things that
are close when you do it. But you got to
balance it out just like anything else,
I guess. I'm sure I don't use
my iPhone to the abilities.
I understand what Ari went
back to the flip phone. It's too
much of your time consumed. Yeah,
that's what he felt. But I
feel now that uh, you know,
if I can get to get an email, I
like to get my email, you know,
that's very important to me. My main
email, like together, discipline texts.
I'll look at your fucking phone off.
I don't give a fuck.
I'm not going to go on there and read
with capital on Yahoo. That's never been,
I don't give a fuck around the rousy.
I told them to do with me when I
should have got nothing to do with me.
I read what's important.
You send me an email or call me.
That's all I fucking know. Right? I don't
know nothing. When I'm out of the house,
you're dead. I don't take pictures.
Nothing. Not Thing I'm done.
I'm out there living on pip paying
attention though that Instagram,
no life is to finance with them.
I have no idea.
I have no fucking idea.
There's a,
there's a certain aspect to it
that I think is pretty cool.
The idea that you can get an alert
on your phone and go check about some
breaking news.
It's happening right now and you find
out about something you would never have
found out about.
I got friends who are like,
they sit in front of the TV waiting for
something to get the phone. You're like,
who the fuck? No, no. I get
it. I got it. I could see that.
I could see that I'm calling back.
I get the message
gps. Just when you're somewhere
you don't not and you're like,
where's the closest Starbucks or
where's something like Ari says it's,
he's not on his phone as much now that
he has his phone bullshit cause he's
spending 10 times longer trying
to type a sentence to me.
Like the other day we're going back and
forth. I'm just like, what is, Oh yeah,
he's on the flip phone and he's like,
yeah,
got it. Takes longer to make
text message. I just call you.
Let's just call this, you
know. That's what I'm saying.
You don't make texts anyway.
I don't want to do it.
I'm going to send nobody pictures.
Don't send me nothing. I'm a simple guy.
Does an infant of infamous video that
Brian made a long time ago of a Senate
Joey Diaz texts. Oh, I was like at the
old Houston lab stuff. That was fun.
That was, yeah. What year was that from?
Joey d is ready to die. It was called
and five and it was, yeah, around that.
It was 10 years ago. Not Crazy.
In 2005 Pete still had that club.
Can you believe that shit?
Wow. That's crazy. It's sad.
That club doesn't exist anymore.
That was one of the all time great clubs.
It's clad though.
Why the club is don't fucking really
not glad that the club was stolen.
Cyst and a lot of new ones have open.
I've gone to a lot of good clubs the
last three years that I didn't even know
existed. Cleveland's a good club.
Indianapolis is a rocking little city.
I had never been there.
Buffalo's always rocks.
How long he in Portland been
around seven years. Seven years.
No Way. Now it's like three or four
maybe. I all I know about Portland.
Portland is Houston.
Texas in 1990 comedy has become the thing
to do and it feels good when you go up
there as a comment. Oh yeah. And Houston,
all the bartenders didn't know your name.
Just some hip guy was down. Let's
go down and have a beer. That's it.
That's what it's become important.
I feel that I like when I go up there,
the afterwards, the food in those
trucks, the, the weather for three days.
That's probably one of the best up
and coming right now. Portland. And,
but all the helium says
Mike and motherfuckers,
all those helium's ain't fucking hour.
He called me the first time he goes,
you were right about Portland.
The Cuban sandwich just fucking premium.
They ain't fucking around food.
Portland is the other place
where I have the ranch dressing.
The other place where you do have much,
they have the spicy ranch dressing over
potato tots. It makes your asshole.
You actually liked some ranch dressing?
No revelation.
That's the lady told me after I ate it,
it's was my fucking ordered it. It came.
It's paint. It's red. It's like
for ego. Well it's probably like a,
it's not really like the ranch.
You motherfuckers either the home
ranch mixed with red hot, got malaria.
No,
there's a lot of like crafts restaurants
up there that are making their own food
that she makes the wrong songs and
there's a fucking place I instagrammed it.
There was a truck that we went to. It
was a tie. Cheeseburger. Holy Shit.
It was good. What was ana? Oh
my God. That peanut saute sauce.
Hot Peppers for like a grilled Jalapenos.
I don't know what kind of cheese it was.
There's a bunch of other shit on it.
I had two of them. I had to go back.
I couldn't even fit it in my stomach.
Like I crammed that fucker down
my throat because it was so good.
It was so delicious.
I mean,
it was probably the most delicious
cheeseburger I've ever had in my life.
That's it right there. It's
called the brunch box. Yeah.
You don't even tell by that picture.
That picture.
It's got bacon on it is a cheeseburger
and see those fucking grilled Jalapenos
and could God, it was good
fucking a man. I was like,
I can't believe how delicious it says.
Like it was so unique.
It was such a bunch of
different flavors in your mouth,
but they're like into
shit like that down there,
like little small businesses that do
a great job and make really good food.
It's like it's an art form to a lot
of these people and that's why they,
I think that's why standups
sorta thrives in that city too.
It's a very creative city.
Standup is amazing there.
That fucking helium was
spectacular. Spectacular. So fun.
The fucking staff to the people
Refa took the food to the weather.
It's kind of, you know, if you're here
for a month and it's fucking sunny,
you go up there and it's got
like that Batman weather,
like Gotham siblings like fucking gloom.
You appreciate that later me come home.
Yes you do. You know, and when I went to
Cleveland it's like fucking with Batman.
I just told them the real Luzia everybody
the joke of this place where I'm from
the plane, you know like Cleveland,
no fuck around and look at you.
When he got played Cleveland hat, that's
Atlanta. That's Cleveland Indians.
Oh Shit. Look at you. I was told I'm not
claiming that. It's hilarious. The the,
at the Portland it's everything's rainy
and so it's all like the green is like a
different green, like the grass. You
don't seem like dry grass up there.
That kras is glowing and globally.
That shit raw. Fuck the juicer.
Pretty pieces of grass. You test
positive and shit. The fuck mean.
As long as he take your vitamin D
because you're not going to get a lot of
sunshine in the winter, but if you
take your vitamin D and deal with that,
is this that it's a relaxed place to,
there's not that many people up
there. I think Portland only has like
a half a million or something. Right.
How many people Google that
shit? I bet. I'm going to guess.
How many people do you guess?
I'm guessing somewhere between five
and 600 times in Portland. Yeah.
At say 1.2 million. No, 2.1 million.
The Wikipedia official population.
609,000 bloons done. Thank you.
Wow. All right, so I've been going to
the mall. I been going to Portland.
It's just 98 I had a friend, Floyd,
the kid, he used to go to die.
I was just like the kid. I used to call
him Floyd. The kids loved Jay Phillips.
He's my brother from different,
my loosening, grand rapids,
Michigan and Floyd's.
Jake Phillips was my friend in Portland,
so I met him during the Seattle comedy
competition and he said, listen,
if you want to come to
Portland I get you to harvest.
That was the big club for years.
That club for five days day,
you want to shoot yourself Saturday night,
the grand finale,
the club owner invites his mother to
the club and she sits in the front row.
Either gives you the thumbs up like
fucking gladiator or the summer's done,
you know? Yeah, she does
his mother. Oh my God.
So they attract a different type.
They attract like comedians,
magicians and hit someone.
Helium went to Portland.
You just knocked him out of the fucking
race. It's two different worlds.
Helium is bringing us killers.
They still got guys that play the
trumpet onstage and jump up and down.
They used to bookstand hope once a year,
the elite club that once a
year they worked at dirty
week and it was either Stan
hope and Ingram or Stan hope and me.
That's it.
One year when we can place in Seattle.
That was like super squeaky clean
at one point was a giggles giggles.
Is that still around? No, the owner,
Terri went back to Utah. He's a Mormon.
He had a club in fucking
whatever that was popular.
So he bought giggles from this dude that
was a fucking pilot in Vietnam and he
was half full box and he used to drive
a Jaguar and he hated dirty comedy.
But he hired me.
I used to put them together to hire me.
But the beauty is I got in with
the waitress. They did drugs. Cool.
So I made the one way just party and
with fucking the singer from Alice and
chains though she used to tell him lanes
anytime you want to come and do some
heroin with, can I use to sit that on on
like I didn't know what else in chain.
Well, I'm not going to lie to him.
At the time I had no idea. And uh,
I used to tell the waitress to go in the
room and see what the feature act was
for the following week.
This is how fucked up this guy was.
So they'd say he doesn't have a
feature of the rest of the month.
So after I'd work on Saturday,
first thing Monday morning nine oh one I
would call him and go whatever his name
was. Hey Joey did and said, can I feature
this week? Let me see if it's open. Yes.
A topic. Hey, let me ask you, when was
the last time you were at the club?
Eight years ago. He was
so old box. He was gone.
Like his mind was gone. Here's the
better one. Thursday night was Olympia,
so you had to drive to Olympia door one
night and then Friday and Saturday night
he had four shows at the club.
Giggles Olympia was one 50 for
the feature and a hundred of show.
She got a five 50 I would go to,
I would do Olympia and then go there
Friday night and take a door off at two 50
and Saturday night. He's still
paying me the five 50 better than me.
I got that guy every fucking week
when I was there. So it was too old.
He just didn't know it was,
no, he wasn't that old. He
was just, he was gone. He did.
And he would ask me on Monday,
when was the last time you were there?
Six years ago. Okay, I see you
Thursday night. It was fucking crazy.
Let me tell you how crazy he was.
So you were on stage and there
was a a window next to the stage.
So that's how you knew when he pulled up.
So I would work dirty,
go up their dicks. Fuck you Cox. And as
soon as I see his light, I count the five.
Soon as he hit the door and he
walked me walking into the back,
I do knock knock jokes.
So I let the girl on fire and we walked
through the jungle and that and he'd
leave. Watch it for a minute. I met,
I had to be cleaned for one minute and
then he disappeared and then you went
right back to your routine. But here's
where it gets better. I worked with,
there's a guy up day,
I can't remember his name,
is fucking great guy out of Seattle.
He's a tennis coach at the University
of Washington. This guy is bad ass.
He's been on the road for years,
did all the TV shows.
He's a gentlemen and the cleanest comic
working and who he was on stage one
night I was featuring for him and that
own the walked in and confused me for him
when he got off the
stage like what the hell?
The matter with you working dirty and
the guy's like, I don't even say a curse.
Bob Bob, that was his
name. Bob. And he goes,
yes you were. I just watch
it being dirty. It was me.
He got shot down and yet
just the mind was gone.
They gave him a check and he hit him up
in Seattle and he bought a comedy club.
He wouldn't even drink. He just
locked himself in his fucking office.
So he sold it to Terry and Terry wanted
it all clean and then it went on and
that was in the u district.
That club, isn't it?
What's The u district and say putting
the club and sits on across the street
from Oakland [inaudible]
you're going to customers.
You have the u district where the
University of Washington Heights.
It was a couple of treats away from
the main strip where everything crack
cracker lax. That's a
great, interesting strip.
That's your Bruce Lee opened this first
fucking school. Really right up dad yet,
bro. Seattle. Bruce Lee walked
around Seattle dog. That's wild,
and he opened his first school up
there and not what you get man,
but with those black guys, that's
where it all started. That was,
there's a large Chinese immigrant because
they went there and he came to Oakland
up.
It was what all the rumors came that the
mafia went and told them not to teach
white people and they told
him to suck his dick. Then he,
then they sent the dragon over there,
send the dragon and
kicked him in the spine.
He went to the hospital and that's
when he wrote the Tao of Jeet Kune Doe.
That's a story that day in the movie.
That's not what happened.
They did send people over and they
were going to fucking kill him.
Those fucking try ads, but that's not
what you think. They did kill them.
I ultimately, 10 years
later, you know, listen man,
you got to put money in their pocket.
Once you put money in their pocket,
they keep you alive. Once wanted
to deal with and could a dragon,
that's all an American deal. That's what
happened. He cut him out of wherever.
Find out the truth about that.
That would be,
that would be unbelievably fascinating.
Document really killed documents.
But then 30 years later they killed
his son and nobody went to jail.
I stuck man. Put a bullet in the
fucking gun with what you were talking.
It's like a piece of
a bullet or something.
Whatever the fuck he went to jail for
that there wasn't a trial. Nothing. Linda,
Linda Lee went up there.
I miss my son.
They must have given
her a fucking check too.
She's worth gazillions when the late,
yeah. Think about it. Who gets the estate?
His two kids, the daughter and
Linda Lee. That's it. Who's left.
He may give Dan Inosanto a
fucking taste from it. Yeah.
The uh, the, there's a lot of
theories about this guy's death.
It's really interesting. I was,
listen guys, I'm 52 years old.
Not only was I there, I mean I wasn't in
China when he died, but I was dead guys.
I was in the middle of this. This
guy was my everything. Joe Rogan.
I had been hit in the
head with a lunchbox.
I was a quiet kid and it was like
that girl that fell off the bike.
She got no titties. She wouldn't give me
pussy. But after she got hit in the head,
she grew tits and she sucked everybody's
Dick. I my worry about that girl.
And he would tell him me how they hit
the side of a lump in their head where
they get to true. When she got very,
uh, what's the word? Sexual, you know,
I got crazy.
So what fuels my craziness was Batman.
But when Batman fought the Green Hornet,
that took me to different levels of
craziness. My father had just died.
I was beating everything up. I used to
have a French poodle. I used to kick.
My mother told me, you know, you
got, and it fueled me. It killed me.
Once Bruce Lee came along,
he introduced martial arts to this country
in a different way. Like that was it.
Those karate schools filled up.
My first experience with karate,
which with Rashad's father,
Jedi Bravo's brown belt,
the guy that plays the Brazilians,
your son's father was my first karate
teacher on 90th street and Amsterdam up on
the west side of that and
that was all a black school,
Joe Rohde and you had to carry a gate.
It was a black guy with a white belt and
you had a walk in and give them a car.
None of the card was a gold you fist.
I'll never forget that.
And they had Monday, Tuesday,
Wednesday, Thursday, Friday.
And they would mark when they
come in and they give you the car,
you couldn't talk, you couldn't
fucking talk. You had to
go back. There were signs,
father put your gear on and you had to
go to the front and stand like this and
they like clap.
You got to do the cat stance from here,
from right hand Joburg and you got
to do the whole cat stance and going,
I still remember all that shit.
I still remember my first form.
I stayed with Sean's father. It was
white, yellow, green belt, purple belt.
I stayed with Sean's father,
Rashad Rashad,
but it was fucking famous from the time
I was maybe six and a half to maybe nine.
I went to that karate school religiously
and when they sent me to Catholic
school during the week,
I would go on Saturday mornings
and would be pissed off.
I wouldn't fuck you been all we got
Rashad's father used [inaudible] resigns.
Father used to make you run with your
Guiana in the street with no shoes on.
Whether it was snow or not.
This was,
this was the beauty that was a
different karate in those days. Dog.
It ain't this shit now that they
didn't just give you about pro.
You had got beat up and then
beat motherfuckers up, but
here's the beauty of it.
You had a run in front of the
kids that you went to school with.
They'd be at the playground.
Hey,
you went with a white fucking geek
running down Amsterdam Avenue and shit.
So the next day you'd go to
school and they're like, look,
a fucking Johnny Kung Fu in time and
you got to fight fucking 10 fucking kids
and shit because they'd see you.
This is a different time for folks who
don't know what we were talking about.
Croissant is a handout.
That's his character,
the priests, all the fucking
people that, hey man,
what happened with you and that Brazilian
guy, not that guy. He's my friend.
He's not really Brazilian,
dare I said it.
It's like they're trying to keep this
God damn secret. It's not a Brazilian,
he's an American actor. Slash.
Comedian. A very funny man,
like saw an orange.
So during that Nicky Swanson,
but here's what kills that nick sorts
and that's how he calls it his fucking
name. But here's what the killer was.
Well, I'm involved in all this Joe Rogan.
At the time my mom moves to Jersey and
on Saturdays I have to go to the bar in
Jersey on, have to go to the
Bronx and do the numbers.
When I went to Catholic school on Sunday,
Saturday is my fault.
My step father would pick me up
Thursday night. Friday was movie night.
I needed to go to the root
three fucking driving.
That's why I saw enter the Dragon.
No,
I saw Chinese connection and five
fingers of death. I'm a drop line.
You mother fuckers,
that's when the guy's hand would turn
purple because he do the eye in palm
technique.
That was just on El Rey.
Fucking you gotta give a
shout out to Robert Rodriguez.
He put it on being all dot Hempel or
heads almost fucking blew up. That's all.
That was the first martial arts movie
that was released in the United States
when his hand turned red and I have
to get, he puts it through the guy,
but I saw those too. Here's
another fact. Hit me, hit me.
Here's the fact that
really kills the America.
This is what really throws a twist in
it. Uh, what's his young man's name?
And Jamie put on the date of Bruce
Lee's death and put the date up of the
release event to the Dragon.
Why is, what does it mean?
Go look just telling me what does it mean?
One of the other,
it would happen one week apart.
That's the kinky thing.
This is the biggest movie in the cut.
Do you under the fucking stand me.
This movie came out on the fucking Friday.
By Saturday you were on the phone
with everybody, uncle, whatever.
You got to go see Bruce Lee. He fucked
everything up. When did Bruce Lee die?
August 19th, 1973 to, yeah,
one of the July 20th, 1973.
When did the movie got released?
That was the weird part of it.
And this guy was a fucking John era and
all of a sudden, but look at his face.
Look at his face.
Go back to his fucking face.
Chinese are the best people at
embalming in their fucking face,
in the casket looking at his fucking face.
That guy took a beaten dog,
doesn't even look like him. That's
what they were selling in Chinatown.
A week later, those pictures of
Bruce Lee guided. Click that.
Click that fucking video. See what he
tells you? The fucking truth story.
Looking at that shit. Shelly,
what are you talking about?
The crazy person that's video.
The true story.
What kind of movies?
Watch Kung Fu and yet man,
deadly weapons ever develop bear.
This is just fucking around, man.
That's all it says is that as well.
I'm a,
she's still alive. Yeah.
Billions. Billions.
What he saw Justin in t shirt
weeping. He does a year. Oh yeah,
I got a few of them. The roots of fight
ones. Yeah. This is a bullshit video.
Hold on.
You want to keep watching it?
[inaudible] challenge champion.
Look at that shirt.
That one.
Now hold on one sec. Picture hand
comes up and then put the drag him.
Tell me this guy was in bad shape.
Oh, he has some Hema fucking Toba.
We can just look up the,
we can just look up the death photo
instead of having to watch this horrible
movie they watch.
All of them will be horrible.
Well, he was there for
original wife beater where?
Who are a white theater before
Bruce Lee. Nobody did. Right.
Who the fuck more those?
That wasn't common.
He was the first guy with a six pack
revoke the movie, had a six pack.
Who in a movie we'd show their six pack.
What guy? And a move. Even Chuck Norris,
when you saw him,
you just kind of smooth like no
one never looked like this before.
Like where a guy took his shirt off and
sort of flexing and you see a six pack
and all the sinew and muscles.
Tarzan.
Tarzan was smooth.
Tarzan was like a fit dude,
but he was smooth. No one's
ever done Tarzan. Right?
That's a movie that no one ever
really nailed. Nobody ever really,
you really believe some dudes out there
living with monkeys can't believe you
watched that whole thing and that
death foot it. Even in it. Yeah.
Fuck.
It confuses
people today. Don't know how much of an
impact, personally, you have no idea.
When I wasn't getting a job,
it kills me when I see documentaries
and they're talking for like John Jones.
I Love Jon Jones be at $20 you didn't see
the impact of the black kids trying to
town on Saturdays. We'll be back.
No white kids eat and everything.
I used to go to China town, hit the stick.
It was a cat. A lizard. It didn't matter.
I wanted to be like Bruce sleep,
bro. Yeah matter. I had the shoes.
I had the thing I didn't sense
at the house. Me and mom,
my mom's a Santa Maria check. She'd come
in like, what the fuck is this incense?
Get this. Are you fucking crazy?
I beat and rice for a long time.
I went on a rice diet, was going
fucking nuts. She was like, Oh,
neat and chatty and eat Chinese
food to be like Bruce Lee.
I everything I did everything.
I had the palm that you rub on your hands.
I am Paul. I fucking was trying to get a
plane ticket to Hong Kong. I was crazy.
I was nuts. What's his stuff do
you rubbing your hands to Ramallah?
Cina they have that and then they
have this ointment that you put on.
It's like a liquid. It's like chin,
chin, Tiger Balm. It's a little,
it's a little thicker and you use
it for the IOM palm technique.
So you rub it on your hands and you hit
a bag before you strike something. Ah.
And it really, yeah, it's that important.
You put it on your elbows, your joints.
Remember these to have those stores, you
should buy it. You can buy a Ninja stars.
They just haven't been Chinatown.
You could go by throwing stars. Yeah,
but there will never be sharp you.
I'm really going to war.
I got four stars on my pocket.
I really throw it out a motherfucker.
And then other than that,
not even sticking into would
that have been told you?
You've got to take them home and sharpen
them. That was always the fucking,
by the way,
the ones that were going in Boston,
they said they sold ones
that had sharp edges to them.
I used to get black belt magazine and
granted that was my magazine is a narrower
sharp though cause I got a few of those
and we'd be like, throw me against walls,
century martial arts catalog.
You'd get that catalog.
You can order all kinds of
shit. Coco Bolo, noon chucks.
I was not telling him [inaudible] I
used to get my shit from the Honda.
Honda was the random martial arts
and they had a store on Broadway,
a fifth avenue. When you go in there
as a martial arts kid, you would come,
your head would blow up.
When I was 10 I would save all my money.
I would work at a bar and I would go
over there and I'm Saturdays was 600
gorillas.
This was way before weed.
This is what you lot of
people don't understand.
I stayed in martial arts and the reason
why I quit was because those kids didn't
get hot. I couldn't, I couldn't hide it
from them. No one. I liked those guys.
You know, I used to go to class and in
those days I went to my mother's Bar,
a done and I went to karate and
in those days you were a kid,
but you went to the kids' class and you
stay for the men's class and the men
fucked you up. And that's the
guys that helped the board feet.
The upper belts would fuck you up.
I would leave there at nine nine 30 and
walk home after two hours of that shit.
And sometimes we'd go, I go
to North Bergen, go to my
house and go to Mario Diaz,
his house. He was a Chinese Cuban
kid and he had a basement and that,
that's where everybody met. Like in those
days, there was no Brazilian Jujitsu,
contrived in the tournament's.
Did you ever fight? Yeah,
but I thought semi contact I here,
my leg would always slip and I'd hit
you in the head and I get disqualified,
but I always won first place in the form.
So my goal was February of 1979 I had
a goal on my birthday to 19 I said,
I'm going to go to this tournament. It
was a regional New Jersey, torn them.
My goal was to take first place and
the form first place and fighting,
and I was going to quit Joe road.
That's it.
I was going to go to that tournament
that Sunday and quit and never go back to
karate. I was gonna focus on basketball
and I went to the tournament.
I got disqualified for kicking butt. I
took first in the form and on the way out.
Good forums. Yeah. This was
when I was issued a rule karate.
This was on 22nd. The guy's name was
Nelson Orleans, the Wayne Orlando.
He was another Vietnam. That boat. He
white dude like Chuck Norris. And uh,
he looked at your report card? He
was, he was a little bit more serious.
He didn't really, it wasn't a nice
guy, but he had good for him. You know,
he had good karate taught
and that was the last,
that was the last when I left there
I think I was a green daughter. So,
so that's when you were doing these forms?
Yeah. Do you think you remember those?
Like when you did that Joey karate thing?
We used to run around throwing kicks
and punches. That was part of it.
Those little moves.
I still remember one form that you learned
what you put your hand down the elbow,
you let them go and then punch. It was
like a really neat for him, you know,
because I used to hang out with food.
Job Pie Kung Fu guys.
I used to hang out with
how Kido motherfuckers,
I used to hang out with a couple
of Cubans that were into judo,
you know one time and you city that
had a huge rush and judo school.
There was also William Bolt.
He was directing. He was
the original Ikea though,
Dude. Oh Shit. Oh Shit.
I'm telling you. I had my homemade
heads. This video have Nah, Nah, they,
they keep putting in box 6,000
they keep redoing them and shit.
Who's is this? Do you have a youtube
page? There's not somebody else's shit.
Oh my God. She didn't have a youtube
page where this shit is all up.
I don't even have, I think Damon has
the originals and shit like that.
This is probably Daymond's well
you is that his a youtube channel?
Fuck the Owens Joey karate
for the UFC minute.
A lot of people see me on the
medical mile all the time ago. Huh?
A lot of people see me
in the sports reports,
but nobody really knows how
many trains fucking assassin.
I lost my rent on the fucking boat ride
over. It knocked me Donald Greenberg.
I'm fighting to get it back.
You understand me?
I take my shit's guide fucking
jungles in China. Hong Kong,
Bolivia.
That's why train with fucking savages.
Fucking guys flying through the air.
But you're lucky you caught me today.
Joined karate is going to give you a
lock for UFC and it's all about fucking
Brazil this week. He
understand me. My man,
Anderson Silva isn't a fuck people
up this weekend in the Sammy.
He went through Chris Leben,
Chris Leben, forest
Whitaker, forest Griffin.
Let me show you what this
motherfucker though. First off,
he's going to get them in a clinic.
That's a movie type shit. You know it's
not really a dialing over
the Thai restaurant. I'm
fucking guy with it, Susan.
We got them in the clench. Couple
knees to the fucking head. A kick.
I'm going a sidekick.
He's a gentleman to some fucking
Samurai or some on bar or some fucking,
and he's in a book and chop them up.
It's that simple.
Why don't you do your Joey karate
predictions because you got to move on.
You gotta move on. These are amazing
though. I can't do this no more.
I'm too old to old people would say,
who's this fucking fat old guy trying
to be shit. Don't listen to them.
I'm going to hang up.
Wow.
Every once in a while you
gotta hang up the gate dog.
He can't be doing that shit on national
Tyrone ups for. I think you should do it.
I love it. I love all that.
That's my love for it. I,
I had it so I know how much it affected
me. After that, my life went downhill.
The next six months in my life were
a disaster after her martial arts.
I hit the number. Yeah. When
I quit to it, that was it.
That was the beginning of that. Six
months later, my mom died. It was all,
but when I got my life back together,
that's what it was.
I got back into its great for people.
Now you need to do predictions for fights.
I'm too out of it anymore. But you're
good at it. Even if you're wrong.
It's hilarious. Listen, I, I felt
in my heart those shiny nose,
but I couldn't say it.
People don't think you see the fight.
You got find credible pedes
versus, oh, Sandra's pedis.
I thought Pedis had an edge in the
standup for showers are great car.
The girl Joanna, she
hits hard. Uh, you know,
over and everybody's jumping
up and down over road, right?
Don't get to fucking excited.
It was a pretty good proof point
for this test to come back. Oh
wait for the test to come
back on Thursday. All right.
Before you guys started jumping up
and down, he beat up Roy Nelson,
poor Roy Nelson.
You know,
a lot of people said that after
the fight dos Anjos they go,
please don't touch these all
ripped unbelievable performance.
Like this guy,
he's gotta be like somehow or another,
this guy's got to get through this.
That was incredible. I thought.
I really did think that pet is going to
have an edge in the standup and dose on
Joseph was just uh,
just attacking from the very
beginning of the fight in the standup,
like lit him up man.
Straight left hands like super fast.
Like faster than I've ever seen him
fight before. His last two fights.
He's looks sensational. He looked
a level above his game. So,
uh,
I just,
I didn't know it was going to be that
I really did from the beat more of a,
but he took away. He took them
down and that way bro, that's the,
that's the fucking thing sometimes
just doesn't take down. She has paid.
That's how you know Chael Sonnen
that take down slows you down man.
That was some great fights in that car.
You know what else it was though too.
It wasn't just the takedowns,
it was the fucking kick to the body
that left power kick to the body.
He was smashing
them with that thing. Every time
you get hit with a kick like that,
that should takes a lot
of your movement away.
It takes a lot of your breath away.
It takes a lot of your energy
away till Sandra just smashed on.
What that kick over and over again
and smashed. And what's trait lefts?
I think pedestals just taken a back.
I just don't think he expected it.
I think he felt like the dose on Joe's
would be probably slower than him and
move a little more hesitant on the
feet. But those aren't just, just, just,
just attack.
I am a big fan of fights. This particular
fights at my dick gets hard. Yeah,
that was a big one for me. That was
a big one for me. But what's coming?
Cause whatever happens with Serone
and look a walkie, the Russian
beep, that bad motherfucker with the war
had mother for whatever happens there.
I can't even pick a winner.
Like it's too much for my fucking
scalped even thinking about.
So whatever happens that fight to
where that gets this fucking savage.
So that's two fights. I get to see that
it gets hard and it spills all over it.
So I love it. This is tremendous.
I love this type of shit.
My original fight was dropped
array against Yoel Romero.
That went down to fucking
see you get that name right.
Every time there was Cuban
and the names just flow it.
I know y'all well remember it was easy
as just today is nobody fucks up jocker
Ray's name yet. I believe Nijmegen
Madoff. That's too much from him.
It's crazy because you know what?
You can't say it.
10 years ago you guys were talking to me
about Jackie, right? Yeah, he's Boston.
Years ago when you had,
he had the tape.
We'll get those cars that
would do an hour by Jack Rail.
It's like nobody talks about them in the
UFC and he's more dangerous than ever.
They just don't fight that motherfucker
know well, he's been injured.
He's got a good two pretty
significant shoulder injury.
He, I know he had surgery.
He had showed low injury.
He had did something but know no,
that guy's fireworks at that weight
level and see what he did to,
you should know Cami. It was fucking
smashing. You shouldn't call me. Yeah,
you shouldn't. Was done by his,
his attacks monster. He's
putting together, you know,
it's very nice to see guys like
nobody.
Nobody, nobody. First of all,
nobody would have called 10 years ago
that the UFC would be as big as it is
today, but nobody really thought Robbie
Lawler would put the pieces together.
You know, it happens to comics.
You've seen him 10 years ago,
they go to Montreal to get a little
success to deal, doesn't fall through,
and instead of putting the tail
between their legs, they become comics.
They keep working and you'll
see him 10 years later.
Now they're fucking powerhouses.
Powerhouses was the same thing
happens in fighting. I believe it.
You know this guy that does this,
he takes a couple of losses.
He gets better and better and
better and next thing you know,
his ground game now is part of what is
striking is striking is part of this
wrestling. You know, it just
all fits and once it all fits,
you're not going to stop somebody.
You're not going to stop me for a
while till they overthink themselves.
Once they overthink themselves,
that's like commonly give or this off,
he'd go up to
you don't get the reaction you want.
Keep it fucking simple bitch.
Fuck are you to overthink things
once we start thinking of this,
when we kill ourselves, but I see
it, I see where Robbie Lawler,
guys like Robbie Lawler have to really
make you believe in any of the field that
you may do, whether you're an artist,
the singer, that you know what?
You took your lumps for a few years. You
really did man, but something you did,
whatever you're doing now,
stick to it.
You said it was because he
wasn't inspiring anymore. He
just says, yeah, you know,
it's, it's, people put the pieces
together. That's not what he did though.
He got better once you started
sparring again real, but no, no.
He put the pieces together after 10 years.
He was a good fighter.
He was a slugger. When it is, is American
top team. That's a big one. It's huge.
He went to a real big gym and he
got really dedicated and you know,
he became a more mature man. You
know, he's in his thirties now.
He's a real mature professional
athlete now. It's just,
he was a wild motherfucker when he was
young, but now he's a real champion.
I mean Robbie trains like a fucking
champion and he always had the ability.
He always had the mindset for sure.
And now you're seeing just the fruits
of his Labor. He's just, he's grown up,
he's got a wife and a kid now.
It's a different animal and now he's a
totally different animal and he's, he's,
you know, he's coming out for blood,
man. He's coming out for blood.
Jonny Andrews look good. Look real good,
good. Danowitz it didn't like that fight,
but that's looked for guy to do that
to Matt Brown holding down like that.
Beat him up like that.
Like I was impressed.
I was impressed that that's how you're
supposed to fight when you can wrestle
that way.
Why would you stay?
I mean everybody wants everybody
to fight in a way that's not smart.
Like for a guy like Johnny Hendricks,
that's a smart way to fight. You.
Throw some punches on your feet, take
that motherfucker down anytime you want.
Beat him up when he can.
And when you got a guy like Matt Brown,
you better do that. She has
peaked. Did a federal judge. Yeah,
but you just did it for years. You got
to do that with a guy like kind of brown.
You wouldn't even stand up with
them. That's, that's crazy.
You have a huge advantage. If you
take him to the ground on your feet,
you're pretty much dead. Even if you
just decided to slug it out with them.
I mean Johnny might have more one punch
knockout power because Johnny had some
pretty crazy one punch knockout.
So when people go flying,
like he's got magic in his hand.
Like that red hand from Kung Fu.
Like he sends guys flying like
doesn't do it as much anymore.
But like if you go back to some
of his highlight reel knockout,
it's like the John Fitch one or the
Martin Kampmann one. They go flying,
he says blam he just cracks
him with that left hand.
So you add that and then the boy tie
of Matt Brown, Matte Miles Nasty.
You know Johnny might be able
to hit harder with one shot,
but Matt Brown was knocked
some motherfuckers dead
too and he comes after you,
man. You know, if you just going to
stand with him and just trade with them.
Robbie Lawler did it,
but Robbie Lawler's the fucking champ.
You know he went five rounds with
Matt Brown and he's going to do Robbie
Lawler's going to fight Rory Macdonald
again. That's going to be fucking crazy.
Was that? I think that's Hebrew.
Where? When is that? I'm not sure.
I want to say. Hmm. I don't know man.
Uh, 89 July 11th July.
Oh, okay. Jesus Christ.
That's the big one in Vegas.
Oh,
what's July 11th that's the Big Vegas
coach, which was that? Who's done that?
Who's on that? Who was on that car? Jamie.
That's international fight week and
last week. Big One dude. Sub Dog. Wait,
that's a big one. So you know I
love it. That is a giant card.
That's the July card. Uconn
McGregor versus Josie Aldo. Who?
Jesus fucking Christ. That's right.
Oh good Lord. That's a fucking,
I have an answer now. That's all
you have. That's all you need.
That's all you need this for that.
What are you going to put this already
sold out? As soon as it gets on sale,
it sold out the,
they're going to the amount of people
that are going to come over from Ireland.
There's going to be people watching
that shit. I'm close to her kid.
It's going to be all throughout the
Vegas is going to look like Ireland.
It's going to be madness.
Madness.
Nobody brings motherfuckers like that guy.
That guy brings a lot of
fucking people to the fight.
Fuck Saint Paddy's Day.
Wow.
Robbie Lawler and Rory Macdonald and
Josie Aldo and Conor McGregor on one car.
My God. Good Lord God. Keep
together. Please, please,
please. You know, right now
it's march, April, May, June,
three months for some bad shit
to happen to someone's knee.
Three months for somebody to get
put the kiss of death because
the speech itself, it's interesting
like when this is happening too,
like what time in their career,
you know,
Mcgregor on the rise and all those
been a champ for a long time.
Like it's a good time.
If Mcgregor was gonna fight them,
now's a good time to fight him.
And he's had so many really tough fights.
Really wars, you know it's
fucking interesting fight man.
Really interesting fight.
And then Robin and Rory is going to
be interesting to map five rounds.
You know, who knows what the fuck's
going to happen and that fight.
Who knows what like strategy
Roy's gonna Employ Roy.
He apparently had something
wrong with his ankle.
He was talking about it when
he came in here for that fight.
Couldn't move around as
much as he would like to.
Stood right in front of Robbie
when wonder when he's going out,
how he's going to fight him
when they fight in July.
Cause you know he got a lot better
since then. Rory got a lot better.
Robbie got better since then.
They both got better.
Ravi being the champ now he's
going to really have like,
he's going to have a pretty significant
advantage as far as like confidence and
mindset.
Like having already beat him once,
beat him and hurt him and
then now also being the champ.
But that doesn't mean anything
man. Rory, he's talented as shit.
He's a really fun guy to watch Roy
because he's such a student of fighting,
you know, he doesn't have like ridiculous
athleticism, ridiculous knockout power.
It just does everything great. Everything
he does is great, knows what to do.
It's foot works. Excellent.
Real smart about it. An
interesting dude on the podcast too and
if you listen to the one that I did with
him, it's one of my
favorite ones with fighters.
He's a real down to earth dudes
to totally honest about it too.
Like the way stairs down guys. Like, like
it looks like dead in the eyes and shit.
And he's like,
well dude was staring at me and I
didn't want to turn away like a bitch.
It's like, instead of sounding
like subset of a psycho, it's like,
well I guess that makes sense.
What's the next Joey Diaz when he doing,
what do you got going on this weekend?
We uh, I'm here with you guys. Yeah,
you're all here all weekend. Yeah,
I'm going to Ebi dog. Oh, that's
right. And Ebi Sunday. Eddie Bravo.
A invitational Jujitsu
tournament this Sunday.
We're going to go check that out at the
Orpheum in La and then a Sunday night
I'll math the place where
Joey's not allowed to work.
The comedy magic paper view for Eddie,
the roasting on a pay per view for either,
you've got to look into it. I'll be
tweeting, it's going to cost or whatever,
but please it's going to be great. They
have a lot of fucking young guys on the,
uh, you know, I'm going to be scary.
You have to to fucking animals from
coast Mesa. A lot of good fighters,
Jujitsu, Jujitsu. This is the one for you.
Cock suckers that he brought was really
working on it. This and as a brother.
I'm like, last time I fucked
up this time I got it. Yeah.
They're coming in to Gary and Eddie
are going to come in and hopefully on
Saturday we're going to do a podcast,
talk about it, pump, pump it up.
So you're in town for a few weeks.
I'm in town and go to San
Diego in about three weeks.
I go to fuck and Tempe and I go
to Houston. Beautiful. You know,
and the month of April,
where are your dates up?
But they up at Jody has done that.
I put 'em up today because I
finally got everything together,
but I'm still got three or four
like I pop in. So just work with me,
work with them, work with me.
You Mad Flavor on Twitter?
The only person I know that doesn't
have his actual name as is Twitter.
Very important. Very important.
The reason why I came early,
it was to promote the last, uh, this is
not happening. What are reached your fear?
It's me and our, your
fear. I tell a story,
but my mom's friend who took care of me
after my mom died and I never gave her
any props and that's it.
Please just that's tomorrow
night DVR. Yeah. 11 o'clock.
Do what's the favorite? The last one
of the seasons, it's 1230. Right?
It's a different time.
1230 1230 eastern tomorrow.
It's the last season Joe did last weekend.
Please watch it and just kicked out of
the DV. I'll tell your neighbor, you know,
if you have a direct TV,
it'll be on east coast time.
So if you're on comedy central,
Directv,
it'd be 9:30 PM if you will have a lot
of different cable companies will have it
on a regular west coast time,
which means it'll be 1230 and 1230 on the
east coast, aren't you? Fucks all right.
That's it. Can I love you?
Let me take it back later.
Red Bag.